all right good morning everybody
today is
january 19th it is wednesday this is the
new hampshire house election law
committee we have a number of bills
scheduled to be heard starting at 9 30.
we are a few minutes late but even
starting a few minutes late i would like
to start with the pledge so if you could
join me in rising with the pledge to
the flag i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america and to
the republic for which it stands one
nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you everybody the first bill we
have before us today is
hb1009
requiring the date a person registers to
vote to be included with other voter
information the sponsor of this bill is
representative sweeney representative
sweeney
is a member of this committee but is
traveling this weekend out of the state
here to introduce the bill is
representative ross berry welcome to
this side of the committee table thank
you madam chairman i am the
much smarter better looking
representative sweeney today
um
we have a a highly controversial bill
madam chairman of adding the date of
voter registration to
the information available to the
approved parties on the electronic
checklist
so all it does is add the date that the
voter registered
and nothing else
question
if you know since this is not your bill
is the intent for this to be retroactive
or forward-looking
they already have the information so i
don't know if it's retroactive it's just
available
questions from committee members
representative hamlet
oh thank you madam chair thank you
representative
um
is there what is the reason for this
bill of uh of needing to know the
when a person registered to vote yeah i
can't speak exactly for the sponsor but
uh i do believe it gives a more complete
um picture of the voter as a whole um so
you know is this a new voter is it they
just move here right um you know as a as
we campaign i would like to know if
somebody lived in the neighborhood for
two days or 20 years
okay thank you
other questions from committee members
representative bergeron
uh no i don't believe so and we did
consult all right we basically i know
the sponsor did consult with the
secretary of state's office on this
because the um i believe he has an
amendment coming forward um because i
think it's actually might be in the
wrong section
but i know he did speak with the
secretary state's office about this and
this information is available in most
states so i would i would
i don't see how that would be
confidential
further
it address questions
either within the district or from one
district to another be
of some interest
i'm thinking
maybe someone from ward one suddenly
moves forward
technically a new voter in ward but
yeah so i think to get to that point i
mean you're right it would be nice to
know that sort of things um but
the reality is is when you move from one
voting page to another you're a newly
registered voter in that in that area so
i'm not exactly quite sure the point of
your question but if you want to put the
more information you want to make
available that is not let's call it
personally invasive
i would i'm supportive of that because
it's a transparency issue for me
thank you
further questions from committee members
i'm seeing none so thank you
representative barry
i do not have any other pink cards on on
this bill is there anybody else present
who would like to speak to the bill that
the committee is currently hearing which
is hb1009
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the public hearing on hb100
the next bill we are going to hear is 12
and that will be at 9 45 so we are in
recess for a few minutes
that's true
all right i am exercising the discretion
of the chair and that i have three time
keepers in front of me none of them are
the same so i am declaring it
9 45.
this is the house election law committee
we are scheduled to have a public
hearing on house bill 1252
this is an act relative to political
contributions made by certain business
entities and here to rep to introduce
the bill is the prime sponsor
representative love representative love
do i have a pink card from you no
all right but i'll have one from you
before you leave right okay great thank
you welcome representative love
thank you madam chair and members of the
house election law committee
this morning i come before you to
introduce house bill 1252
and house bill 1252 will if passed and
signed into law prohibit any person or
entity that receives taxpayer-funded
grants from the state of new hampshire
from donating to a pac or state
political campaign
i was speaking with a new hampshire
executive council on sunday evening
about this bill and he told me that this
happens more often than people realize
he told me about a a fish and game club
that was applying for a grant and they
realized that this fish and game club
had made
donations to a pack
and
i
i don't know if they
approved it
or not but um you know uh to me that
that's just flat out wrong the the
taxpayer doesn't expect their their
money their hard-earned money going to
going into uh to packs or political
campaigns
um
let's see uh
we can't go very deep into a political
discussion without constituents uh
hearing without with constituents
without hearing we have to get the dirty
money out of out of the elections and
that's
when you when you're taking taxpayer
money and putting it into an election
that's real dirty for me
that
and that's what this bill is about quid
pro quo it's dirty money and we need to
stop this practice in new hampshire
while discussing this bill with
colleagues the question of first
amendment rights has come up
so i asked our colleague from windham
the the former chief justice of new
hampshire superior court uh his and his
response was they gave up their first
amendment rights when they took the
taxpayers money uh there is an amendment
that i had drafted that uh that expands
this bill a little bit but uh that's for
later and uh
no actually representative love why
don't you um
representative prudhomme o'brien as has
indicated to me that she will introduce
the amendment when we are executing the
bill so why don't you
address it now okay and
frankly thank you for having the
amendment done while we're hearing the
bill it's frankly i think much more
useful for the committee than getting it
when we exec
okay um let me
pull it out here
and what what it does is uh you know it
expands it a little bit uh to uh
to any person or business entity that
has received a grant subsidy or a loan
from the state of new hampshire in the
last two years
and uh you know any person found found
in violation this paragraph shall be
ineligible for a grant subsidy alone
from the state for the next 10 years
you know put a little teeth into the
into the penalties and um
i'll take any questions
thank you representative love questions
for representative love
representative
really just one bergeron
what about federal pass-through for
example uh
um
well
maybe we'll need an amendment to address
that uh i didn't think of it
representative alexander thank you madam
chair and thank you representative um i
guess that's the follow-up anybody
receiving like community um during the
covet pandemic anybody receiving any
grants
or funding at all which is most most
businesses that applied
anybody
they wouldn't qualify they wouldn't be
able to make any donation i i did not
think of it and i i'd welcome enough an
amendment to fix that up okay
further questions
representative taurosian
thank you madam chair thank you
representative taking the question
you did address the on the state level
um the
concern about
the potential of violating
the first amendment right of the
individual uh
with the business
but it's my understanding that federal
law has ruled on this before too and and
found that there could be a potential
first amendment right
violation to restrict
an activity like this
was that brought up or when you did your
research was any
information on that
my research was uh just uh
asking um you know the representative
from windham and uh you know i uh
the the man knows a little bit about law
so
i i took his word as
uh his
gospel i guess you could say
further questions
representative barry
so i i have a
i think very highly representative lynn
on this issue um wouldn't
wouldn't we have to like structure this
to where it was a part of state
contracts
or because then i couldn't think there
might be a first amendment violation i
understand because i've done
government contracts before and there's
all sorts of stipulations in there for
everything that you can imagine
but they're part of the contract we need
to make it a part of the actual contract
or grant or is this just do we have the
authority to do something sweeping like
this
um
thanks for the question uh i guess we
could uh you know what it did
it uh you know having having this having
this in statute and on the uh grant
alone or subsidy application uh would
certainly uh suffice
further questions i have a question
um
let's let's take
take
i was going to say let's take a look at
something that's non-controversial but
there's nothing that's non-controversial
but i'm going to go there anyways
let's say my
old grasmere town hall
has a
the restoration of the grasmere town
hall has got a volunteer
board that's been established to accept
donations to help fund the restoration
and this board also receives an l-chip
grant
so that would be state funds right so is
that organization now prohibited from
lobbying
the
organization that decides who gets the
l-chip grants or is that board now
prohibited from donating any money to a
flyer to all representatives in support
of the l-chip program
thanks for the question i don't believe
they're prohibited right now um you know
otherwise uh you know that that
executive councilor wouldn't be wouldn't
be discussing that with me as a uh so
you think that should be prohibited so
this so this the effect of that would be
to prohibit that kind of lobbying sure
um you know okay
the text the taxpayers of colebrook
don't expect their money to be gone um
you know these are
these are uh
you know grants that that help
uh you know indigent people uh whatever
um you know help get uh get some
projects done you don't have to be
lobbying to
you know you can do it on on face value
not with money you know that's taxpayers
money it's not corporate money all right
so and so
do you know um
okay thank you
any other questions
representative
ward sorry go ahead
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question i notice this applies to
persons
uh would it apply to an artist let's say
who gets an artist advancement grant
from the new hampshire council on the
arts
absolutely um
once again i don't
everybody
you have to take the taxpayers as a
group and everybody in that group does
not agree with
funding the arts okay i
be honestly i i'm not a big fan
so why should my why should my tax money
go
to
to something like that um stand on your
own two feet
you know if you if you're if you're at
work uh you know um can um
can draw interest and uh and you can
make some money on it fine i don't like
subsidizing businesses and that's what
an artist is actually is he's trying to
sell his his works
so
okay follow up
thank you for that answer it's very
illuminating uh how about a scholar who
gets a grant for historical research
from the humanities council they would
be prohibited from supporting a
candidate do they need to
they they have a they have a
a real and honest um
project
why can't they come before uh you know
the the uh the entities giving the
grants and present their case
and
and get it on face value you know why do
we have to pay why do they pay with take
with with taxpayer money
okay
the taxpayers don't want their money
going to go into pet projects
thank you
okay further questions
representative lane um thank you madam
chair uh thank you representative
my question would is this going to apply
to entities that get sba loans
because most small business a lot of
small businesses in this state get sba
loans
and that's federal that's federal money
but it is
distributed by the banks and so and
there's a lot of different loan programs
not just related to covid
that are also state programs
so any business that gets one of these
loans is not going to be able
if it's direct taxpayer money which an
sba loan isn't it's the bank making the
loan um you know that that's different
well the money they're just they're just
backed by the state or the federal
government okay it's not it's not actual
taxpayer funds that are going to the
loan
a follow-up question follow-up
the money to the sba is coming from our
tax dollars though so if they have to
back that up that is coming from my tax
dollars correct and that's federal tax
dollars that's this is state okay that
we're addressing here
this is just addressing state okay
representative barry
why didn't you include non-profits in
this there are a lot of non-profits that
take millions and millions of state
contracts and then go and shove it into
packs and run campaigns that's why it
says any entity um i believe
i think it says it says business entity
i'm sorry about channels i have a
follow-up yeah no that's that's fine it
says any person business or business
entity um would you be agreeable to an
amendment that included non-profits or
the reduction of business so it is
entity
certainly um you know i i put business
entity because that's to me i that's
whether profit for profit charitable
whatever uh you know um
you viewed the entity as being
encompassing okay yeah
yeah
okay further questions
all right i'm not seeing any thank you
very much representative love who's
going to do a pink card and get it to me
um
is there anybody else here who would
like to speak to 1252
uh well as
as i have been reminded
we have
um sign up sheets both here in the room
and online for people to register an
opinion
there were a few people and i apologize
for not addressing this in the previous
public hearing on
zero nine there were four people who
signed up online
who did not support the first bill we
heard and one person signed in one
representative signed in in favor of the
bill um representative teresa and if you
could get me the blue
for
1252 had
43 people online sign in support of it
two people oppose
and
that was the testimony we received on 12
and as soon as i get that
the blue for 12 52 we will begin the
public hearing on 13 26 and
representative bergeron just so you know
your mic is still on so you might want
to turn it off just because i have no
idea how sensitive the live streaming is
thank you
and 1252
has
three people signed up in support of it
the next bill scheduled for a public
hearing this morning at ten o'clock
and again i have three different
timepieces i'm declaring it ten o'clock
is hb
1326. this is relative to permissible
campaign contributions by business
organizations and labor unions the prime
sponsor is representative reed who is
has joined us today welcome
representative reed
thank you so much madam chair and thank
you again yet again honorable members of
the election law committee for the
record my name is ellen reed i represent
rockingham 17
newmarket and new fields i think i feel
a bit muffled
here we go all right
so
this bill
has been before you a few times it
actually passed in 2020 and was one of
those many unfortunate uh
casualties of the mass tabling event in
the senate um it was before you in 2021
and based on the report in the house
calendar there was a misinterpretation
and i'll explain that in a bit
but it was not voted on by the house so
it's before you again because
there was no uh restriction on uh
introducing it again
so in
the previous versions and if you want to
just look at research from our committee
researchers
we're on
this particular bill so
if committee members want to refer to
that if they have it that would be fine
thank you
in the previous version of the bill i
had the existing paragraph that exists
in rsa
that applies to labor unions
restrictions on labor unions
campaign donations
and then i added an identical paragraph
and i'll explain why in a minute that
said okay and the same exact thing for
corporations
well the report in the house calendar
seemed to indicate that that bill was
somehow treating corporations and labor
unions differently even though the
language of both of those paragraphs was
identical so what i have done in this
version is simply took the labor union
paragraph and added and businesses
so that there's no hopefully there's no
confusion about
the fact that the same exact language is
applying to both labor unions and
businesses
absolutely equally
so
uh in 1907 teddy roosevelt um in this
kind of wave of anti-corruption that
ended up sweeping the nation in the
aftermath of the
robber baron period teddy roosevelt
passed into federal law a prohibition on
corporate donations for campaigns period
and that is federal law today there's
still federal law corporations cannot
donate period
in the wave of that many many states
including new hampshire also passed an
identical prohibition on corporate
donations to campaigns
so we had that language but this is
before things called pacs existed it was
just corporations can't donate
and so in 1999 the court struck the new
hampshire supreme court struck that down
saying it was overly broad the intent of
the original legislation was understood
to not be from general funds
however
the wording was too broad and they said
very explicitly
and i'm going to refer to a previous
testimony on this bill
a previous version of this bill
that i have passed out that
has the quote from the new hampshire
supreme court
saying that there is of course a simple
solution to this problem the general
court can easily and effectively amend
the statute to reflect its actual
constitutional intent
which was simply to say
as we currently do with unions
that yes corporations cannot donate from
their general funds though if a
corporation or any union anyone creates
a segregated fund a pac
where the funds that come in and go out
are completely voluntary the funds that
come in are made by donations from
people who know this is going to a
political cause
separate from the general funds so if
you're a union member dues cannot be
used for campaign donations
and as the previous member mentioned if
you're a business even if you're a
business that gets taxpayer funds those
general funds cannot be used it has to
be a separate segregated fund but then
yes you can donate to political
campaigns
so we have had for since 1999 when the
supreme court struck that law down
a mismatch in our labor union
restriction and our business restriction
business has no restriction even though
they originally had an absolute
prohibition that was struck down as
overly broad now businesses have no
restriction labor unions have the
restriction that must be from segregated
funds all this bill is doing
as it has done in the past when it's
passed is to say same language same
rules apply to both equally
they cannot whether labor or business
donate from their general funds they can
whether labor business donate from a
segregated fund that is for that purpose
and that's it i'm happy to take
questions
thank you
questions from the committee
representative terezin
thank you madam chair thank you
representative taking the question
help me i understand because i'm looking
at the summary of some research that was
done on this that
and i'll read it verbatim that currently
new hampshire statue prohibits political
contributions by partnerships labor
unions and individuals in excessive
specified amounts a previous new
hampshire ban on political contributions
made by business organizations was
struck down in the u.s district court
ruling issued 1999 and ultimately
removed from the law in 2011. if we were
to passed this wouldn't we run into the
same problem
literally no that's i i literally
explained this okay so
the and i even quoted the court just now
in that exact case the court said
the intent is good many states and the
federal government have a prohibition on
corporations
but the intent while good the language
was too broad because it said it is a
complete ban which included segregated
dedicated funds
the court said it's very easy i can
quote it again
very easy for the general court to fix
this by simply saying they can donate
through general fund for through
segregated funds but not general funds
which is what we do for labor unions
right now we treat businesses and labor
unions differently they should be
treated the same which is to say in
keeping with the original legislative
intent and in keeping with the supreme
court recommendation for what our
wording should be
to say that general funds whether
business or unions is prohibited
dedicated funds where those donations to
those funds are completely voluntary and
known to the people to be for political
purposes that is okay
further questions from committee members
representative if he would indulge me
yes ma'am thank you um line seven
six to seven you refer to business
organization and your and i understand
your intent is to be sort of
all-encompassing by that definition
would that be similar perhaps you heard
the previous public hearing when the
bill that we heard used the term
business entity
in an attempt to sort of cover
everything
it's any i don't see the word entity
here no no no that we had a previous
bill that
the language was referred to business
entity and in response to does it
include nonprofits the response was this
is intended to include all businesses of
any kind so is business organization
also an attempt to include
all businesses of any type of structure
i would say not a non-profit in my
understanding i can go to legal experts
for this which you certainly probably
would know more than me about the legal
of it but i would say business
organization officer director executive
agent partner employee acting on behalf
of such business organs i believe that
that means a for-profit entity but it
includes corporations llcs private
proprietorships
it's since profit or non-profit is
really a tax status designed to sort of
give other ways of fundraising the
reality
um
you said you don't want it to apply to
nonprofits no i think it's fine to apply
to nonprofits because that's kind of
already
in effect because of the tax status in
effect what nonprofits have to do
because nonprofits if they're a 501c3
they cannot uh directly electioneer and
they very frequently create a 501c4 arm
in order to do so so they're already
doing this
all right
and then one further question the the
language and for committee members it's
on page three of the report you have um
they they talk about the decision talked
about permitting contributions from a
segregated account funded through
voluntary contributions right
so
in your bill on p online 14 you talk
about voluntary contributions solicited
um i don't have a dictionary in front of
me and i haven't looked it up solicited
means that somebody is out asking for it
in my opinion
so at what point does something
solicited become non-voluntary
especially in an employment situation so
if your employer comes and says hey i
have this fund that i've established for
say peta and i'd like you to contribute
five dollars do you consider that
contribution of five dollars to still be
voluntary
i mean you raise a good point but the
the bill still is just as strong because
it's inclusive of those solicitation
those kind of i guess
um what
what's the word when you coercion
coercion type situations this would be
inclusive of that
so
i
i don't know why this would still be bad
having said that if there's better more
specific language that gets around these
kinds of legal definitions i'm happy to
work with anyone on this committee to to
make an amendment as long as this
committee is understanding and
supportive of the intent of the bill to
treat labor unions and businesses the
same
thank you thank you thank you
representative growing
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative reed for
taking my question are you aware that
there is a very explicit definition for
business organization and it's 664
colon 216
that defines business organization and
it defines it as a for-profit
oh so it is for profit okay there is it
is explicitly defined
oh okay i was not aware and i said that
i didn't have the legal expertise to
know that but that was my suspicion and
thank you for for confirming my
suspicion but again nonprofits already
are under because of federal tax
law are already behaving like this 501
c3s cannot politically
electioneer so they have to create a
pack arm in order to do that
and many many many do
and representative growing gets the gold
star because he remembered to bring the
new book of elections with him which i
carefully took out of my bag and did not
put back in
he represents my committee member goals
right now representative lane
thank you madam chair and representative
um
i guess i would are you aware that there
are many different kinds of nonprofits
not just 501c3s there's probably 15 or
16 so i
okay so when you talk about a non-profit
oh well maybe
no go ahead when you talk about a
non-profit are you talking about five
just 501 c 3s or all the other kinds as
well thank you for the question
representative lane um so no but the
bill doesn't talk to non-profits the
question that originally brought up the
question of nonprofits was does business
organization
include nonprofits and we've just been
educated uh by representative groan that
in fact it does not so there's really no
point in bringing that up having said
that my understanding is there are many
different types of non-profits but when
they pay taxes if they are doing
political contributions
they have to pay taxes they they can't
be
you know a certain category of
non-profit and still do electioneering
so they end up doing this anyway
thank you
thank you so much sorry
um
further questions from the committee
representative growing i see your mic is
on do you have a further question i do
okay
i actually think i see the red light
better than hands there you go
anybody else
all right thank you representative reid
thank you so much madam chair
um
i representative reed is the only person
i have signed up to speak to the bill
we're currently holding a public hearing
on that is hb
is there anybody else here who would
like to speak
to 1326 representative taurosian has
gotten up to get me the blue sheet thank
you very much
there has been remote sign up just as a
reminder you can sign up with the
position on a bill online
the sign up closes either at midnight or
early the morning of the public hearing
signed up online i have 59 in favor one
opposed and we have one person signed up
opposed
so with that not seeing any hands this
concludes the public hearing on hb
1326 and our next hearing will be at 10
30 so we are in recess for 15 minutes
a continued good morning to everybody it
is time for our 10 30 hearing
with the house election law committee
house bill 1394 has been scheduled for
10 30 and this bill is relative to the
reporting of certain campaign
contributions and relative to political
contributions made by limited
liabilities the prime sponsor of the
bill representative lebranch joins us
this morning to introduce the bill rep
welcome back to election representative
lebranch sorry
hello members of the election law
committee my name is representative tony
lebranch and i represent the town of
amherst
i'm here today to introduce house bill
1394 which would tighten new hampshire's
camping finance laws and before i get
into it
i would like to say that i
do not want to appear as wasting the
committee's time but
a recent news story broke about my
departure from the democratic party and
that might have derailed my plans today
for this hearing i had expected more
people to show up but i believe that new
story might have interfered with that
plan
so
i've kept my remarks very brief thank
you representative lebranch before you
continue in my apologies i meant to say
this before
um
you started committee members you do
have research done by christina
uh dyer dated january 17th on hb 1394.
so just so everybody is aware all right
sorry about that interruption go on
uh this bill does two things uh the
first section of the bill would add an
additional requirement to all
organizations that donate within the
state of new hampshire to disclose where
their donors are from
and who their donors are
this is an effort to limit the influence
of dark money being spent in new
hampshire elections and then the second
part is a bill that i believe this
committee has seen very often
is to close the existing llc loophole
which allows for certain individuals to
donate above the current maximum
donation limits
that is the introduction i had planned
for today i had expected more people to
come testify behind me
and i will take any questions although i
would like to keep it brief as i have to
go to amherst town hall to change my
party affiliation thank you
questions for representative lebranch
representative lebranch i have a
question i thought you said there were
two parts but when i read this if you
could maybe just be a little clearer for
me i
read this as being
as you said something this committee has
heard
before that
it's an allocation of the contribution
to members
right
i am pulling up the
bill at the moment
see this is where as an old person i get
to gloat and say paper is quicker
that's something i can agree with
i mean committee members if you're
reading it this is looking a lot like
other bills we've had on this statute
and i think it goes to the
the allocation of the contribution and i
thought i heard representative lebranch
say two purposes
so i'm a little confused so i'm just
looking for clarification representative
lane if or representative lebranch if
you want to address it and then maybe
representative lane yep the first new
section political expenditures and
contributions additional reporting
requirements that was the original
text of the bill uh it was from a
constituent of mine who works for the
organization the people uh and in
talking to fellow members of this
chamber uh
they would like uh to add that llc
loophole i agreed and that is uh okay
what happened thank you that was my poor
reading of the bill and focus on the
highlight to be quite honest
representative lane
thank you madam chair and representative
could you talk a little bit about what
the purpose of this legislation is i
mean maybe you said it and i missed it
but
and we have seen this bill before but
not everybody was on this committee the
last time we saw it
so the first section of the bill thank
you for the question by the way uh the
first section of the bill as i stated
was to
require that all organizations within
new hampshire
that make donations in the state
so this can be political activity
organizations and out of mostly out of
state organizations because i know that
organizations within the state already
have to have to disclose
where their donors are coming from
uh to the second part of the bill about
the llc loophole uh currently uh
individuals who are part of llc's
can donate on behalf of those llc's and
it is a technical loophole that they
could uh donate more than the individual
limit uh
in new hampshire uh i remember last
election i believe it was 1 000 for the
primary 1000 for the general if i recall
correctly i believe that's changed since
then
but because of this llc loophole they
can donate above that uh
that limit
further questions from the committee
i'm not seeing any thank you
representative lebranch also signed up
to speak on this bill
is
brian beal from open democracy and
members you have written testimony from
brian beale welcome mr beale
my name is brian beal i'm deputy
director of open democracy action a
pro-voter nonpartisan nonprofit focused
on the influence of money in politics
the freedom to vote and fair and
competitive voting districts and we're
based in concord
i'm here to speak in support of hb 1394
requiring limited liability corporations
to be added to the types of groups
required to disclose their donors or
investors when making a political
contribution of a thousand dollars or
more
i testified last year on a similar llc
loophole disclosure sorry llc disclosure
bill
i outlined how i had painstakingly
traced the owners of llcs contributing
to campaigns from june to december 2019.
some of those llc's were businesses
making a small contribution but some of
these llc's allowed six families to make
more uh political contributions than the
individual 2019 maximum of seven
thousand dollars totaling
147 000 dollars in that six month period
the consensus of the committee however
was that it was too hard for the
secretary of state's office the entity
which issues corporate and llc
certificates in new hampshire to enforce
such a disclosure
it's true that limited liability
corporations
perform a number of necessary business
functions however as money in politics
politics watchdog open secrets notes
their unique structure may be easily
abused or used in order to hide less
than above aboveboard activities but in
politics llcs are sometimes established
to help disguise the identity of a donor
or source of money spent on behalf of a
political candidate i might add that
we've seen a lot of
donations or llcs involved in issue
campaigns as well
llcs joined 501c3 501c4s 501c6 and other
kinds of organizations as types of dark
money
open secrets puts dark money spending on
which llcs are apart at an estimated 750
million dollars in 2020. of that 121
million was spent on online ads 167
million on television ads and 420
million in
contributions to campaigns
it's important to note that liberal
leaning donors outspent conservative
donors using dark money by a substantial
a margin
one more ray of sunshine for you um out
of state campaign donors and even
foreign campaign donors could be
bankrolling candidates rate
ads and candidates right here in new
hampshire and you would have no idea
you'd only have the name of the llc
which gave the money unless you really
dig in as i said it's a very painstaking
process
some good news for a change
that would matter to this committee
citizens for responsible ethics in
washington also known as crew recently
noted that a revamped fec commission has
finally started to crack down on dark
money groups using llcs for violating
federal finance
campaign finance rules several of these
groups that could
be the best disinfectant
should
1394's amendment uh to our current rules
be approved it would be a good first
step in accountability to shut off this
dark money practice in new hampshire
that both liberal and conservative
funders have been exploiting to the
detriment of we the voters
for those of you who are concerned about
election integrity i've also submitted a
report from issue one
called mystery money how a loophole
could allow foreign money to flow into
super pacs through secretive shell
companies detailing how llc's are used
to keep regulators and the public from
knowing who is influencing our elections
yes that's
federal elections but the same practice
is happening on the state level as well
i ask that you vote ought to pass on 13
hb 1394 and please do this quickly
before the next election and i
appreciate
the opportunity to speak i've added and
have sent to you electronically
this report which also has all of my
links if you'd like to follow up with
the extensive research are there any
questions i can answer
questions from the committee
i have a question thank you kindly thank
you for taking it
um
this bill
no no i have a question
um
i know that you're familiar with the
bill and some of the previous members
are familiar with the concept that we're
talking about sure but this particular
bill as drafted and i don't know that
you have it i mean you're focused on the
llc contribution and attributing it to
the members right i mean that's sort of
the sunshine that you're talking about
and we know that the past dialogue has
been secretary of state's office doesn't
keep track of member information so the
ability to do that requires an
individual such as yourself to dig
through the records to figure it out
but this bill also has an additional um
say
as to that provision because this seems
to be
different than those provisions relating
specifically to the llc my understanding
was that it would add
llcs into
the list of groups that were required to
report
uh and then
what you were discussing earlier the
disclosing
um any donors within that llc
that
that are
that they have to disclose the
percentage of
of
ownership in that llc
okay i'm not my reading of it i'm connie
senator lane
which one am i
i don't know we will all decide at the
end of the day
okay thank you madam chair and thank you
um
uh
are there
the secretary
are you aware of states where they are
disclosing the members when they form
the llc are there states
that do that because i know in new
hampshire we do not
it is my understanding that that
we
don't disclose llc ownership
the report that i gave you from issue
one kind of talks about the process that
they go through when they identify who
is involved usually it's tracking back
to
specific addresses
um
you know the the onus really here is
that we put this in place
those
uh organizations are required to do it
it does mean that the um that the
uh oversight is very difficult
but we would be a whole lot better off
just by requiring this up front
as opposed to trying to track it all
back on the on the back end after an ad
has been run and you know so we want
those we want to make it clear that you
need to to do this disclosure if you're
going to do political activity
how that gets
communicated
um
i'm not clear on you know
other than putting it in the campaign
finance statutes
overseen by the secretary of state's
office
but at least we would have something on
the books that would
kind of put a shot across the bow for
these organizations because 25
28 llcs representing those six
organizations
um and it took me two days
to um get that and process that
information so knowing that information
um
uh
up front and and
forcing these organizations to declare
this information would put us a way
ahead of where we are now
that answer i kind of gave you a
roundabout answer but well
may i follow up
may i follow up yeah follow up
so my my question was
are you aware of other states that do
this so i know what new hampshire
requires but are there other states
that do require
the disclosure of these llc members so
that it is easier in those states to be
more transparent i understand
new york is
an example that comes to mind i know
i don't know what the status of their
llc loophole bill is
it was 2017 2018 it was before the new
york assembly
and they have a very extensive llc
loophole um
law now whether they're whether they
disclose llc members
before political activity
i'm not i'm not clear about that but i
know that they are working very hard in
new york to try and get llcs to um
to uh disclose
when there is political activity
thank you
further questions from the committee
thank you thank you all right yeah thank
you okay
is there anybody else here who wants to
speak to 1394
i'm not seeing anybody so i'm going to
close the public hearing on 1394 there
was remote uh sign up for a position on
this bill
uh 53 parties signed up in support and
one signed up opposed and representative
terozian is bringing over the
blue sheet which is the sign up for
today
thank you representative teresian and
uh two people have signed up for it one
in favor and one opposed
i'm going to close the public hearing on
and open the public hearing on 1423
fna this is also related to campaign
contributions and expenditures and
making an appropriation
for that
and i'm going to recognize
representative marjorie porter as the
prime sponsor to introduce the bill
welcome representative porter
[Music]
thank you madam chair
and members of the committee
it's good to be back here
for the record my name is marjorie
porter and i represent hillsborough
district 1 and the good people of antrim
hillsborough in windsor and i'm here
today to introduce hb 1423
relative to campaign contributions and
expenditures and making an appropriation
therefore
the bill sets up a system for public
funding of elections in new hampshire
a voluntary system
i filed this bill at the request of a
constituent who is here today to testify
and on behalf of open democracy it's a
non-profit which has been steadfastly
working on this issue and indeed this
piece of legislation for years
faith in government and the democratic
system is at a low ebb
citizens look at the huge amount of
money spent on political campaigns
so much of it coming from special
interests
and conclude not incorrectly that the
political playing field is heavily
tilted against them
and when people feel powerless
they disengage and democracy loses its
driving force
the problem is especially acute at the
federal level but new hampshire is not
immune
according to recent polls the citizens
of new hampshire are increasingly
concerned with the influence of big
money and out-of-state interests are
having on elections in our state
indeed the poll referenced in the bill
showed 80 percent of those questions
republicans democrats and undeclared
believe special interests have more
influence than they the voters do
they want things to change
polls also show
wide support for a system of public
funding for elections as a means of
bringing about this change
for almost two decades now there have
been public funding bills study
committees a bipartisan commission and a
blue ribbon task force
all seeking a way to make this happen in
the granite state despite these efforts
no statewide system of public funding
is in existence
knowing that lasting success requires
bipartisan buy-in in july of 2018 a
public financing working group was
convened
six legislators two senators and four
representatives
half democrats and half republicans
madam chair i believe that you were a
member of this working group
their charge was to craft a public
financing bill that would have broad
appeal among members of both parties
hb 1423 is the result
the bill itself is lengthy and detailed
and sets up a well thought out process
for making sure there is fairness
accountability and transparency
but the basics are these
participation in the public funding
system is entirely voluntary and it does
not replace what we have
now
qualifying candidates for governor and
executive council are eligible to
receive voter dollars and if they win
their primary contest additional grants
in election years register voters
registered voters receive four
certificates worth 25 voter dollars each
that they may contribute to
participating candidates of their choice
the voter dollar approach is truly
transformational
incentivizing candidates to seek
contributions from a broad swath of the
electorate and incentivizing everyday
citizens to identify candidates who
deserve their support
and for me this is one of the most
compelling reasons to move this bill
forward places that are using a similar
system are finding increased engagement
of citizens in their processes and
that's a good thing
new hampshire's very late primary makes
it difficult for candidates to raise
enough money for the general election
from small donations alone
grants for primary winners solve that
problem
to become qualified eligible for voter
dollars candidates need to first show
that they can generate enough public
support to mount a viable campaign and
they do this
by collecting small contributions from a
number of people
uh executive council candidates must
collect at least 500 private
contributions of five dollars to up to
125 dollars
a gubernatorial candidate must collect
hundred contributions of five dollars to
up to two hundred fifty dollars
qualifying quant con
qualifying contributions much must come
from registered voters residing within a
candidate's district this would apply to
the executive council
in addition the candidate must publicly
disavow
independent expenditures funds spent by
outside groups or individuals on the
candidate's behalf
participating candidates must agree not
to accept aggregate private
contributions from any one donor for
greater than 125 dollars for the council
and 250 dollars for the governor for the
primary
and similar amounts for the general
no more than 10 percent of private
contribution totals may come from
out-of-state sources
and candidates may not accept
contributions from businesses unions and
lobbyists
there are also strict limits on the use
of personal funds and funds carried over
from previous campaigns
the appropriation we are asking for is
one dollar to set up the fund now
the bill details sources for additional
funding
i believe that passing hb 14 23 will
give granite staters a stronger voice in
government and limit the influence of
wealthy special interests
it will return ownership of our
government to new hampshire's people and
rein in the ability of wealthy special
interests to buy influence in our
democracy
and it will make candidates and elected
officials listen to the will of the
people
i urge you to vote
to pass for hb 1423
i'll be glad to walk you through the
various sections of the bill if that
would help and give you brief details of
it
and i will try to answer any questions
you might have but there are folks
testifying behind me who know the
details of this bill because they have
worked with it for years so i'm sure
we'll be able to give you better answers
than i can on some of them
thank you madam chair thank you
representative porter and so you know
the committee is in possession of
research that was done with the prior
legislation
on it so yeah and i understand that you
might send an email also yes and i
understand there might be an error in
that in that information
i'm not sure though where it is i just
was heard that so that might be
something you want to check
all right representative murrah is
indicating something did you have a
clarification to that comment by
representative porter and if i testify a
little later i can i can okay you're
going to testify okay
all right so i do have a number of
people signed up um
for this including representative
moorhead
so is there anybody here committee
members who have a question for
representative porter
seeing none thank you representative
porter thank you
i'm sort of want to make sure that i do
this in an order that might help educate
the committee
in the best manner
representative guthrie did you want to
speak to this bill welcome
thank you madam chair uh i'm
just for the record i'm uh
representative joe guthrie i represent
uh
rockingham 13 which is hampstead
and kingston at least it is for this
term
and uh i'll only take a short time i
came in and sit down
but
i didn't
agree to be a a co-sponsor for this bill
because i really do believe big money is
in our elections it's just the way it is
they're not going to be able to do
anything about it unless you take hold
of the problem and uh
solve solvent i know this as
representative porter said it's been a
lot of work done in this area uh the
public the
4a is a public financing of elections
and for some people the heading scares
us because it's in the details and i i
suggest to you that this is a very
comprehensive bill
uh it's very detailed and
if i hope it's a at least a working
document it might be some amendments
that you might want to uh put in but i
ask you to take this serious
and it is a big problem and we have to
get big money out of our elections thank
you madam chair thank you representative
guthrie does anybody have any questions
i'm not seeing any thank you very much
for coming
also signed up to speak in favor of this
bill
um
olivia zink olivia do you want to go
because you probably have a pretty good
i'm trying to find somebody who has sort
of maybe more of the mechanics
thanks
okay
and
joe mcgrew is joe testifying no there's
ten testimony in that including mine
okay people that are not there
are not able to make it except for i
think there is one testimony who did
make it okay here
so good morning welcome um
chairman griffin and members of the
committee for the record my name is
olivia zink i live in the city of
franklin and um i am the executive
director of open democracy action which
has 36 000 members
throughout the state
and i'm here to testify and support
reduce the influence of big money
um and increase the voters
you know the voters
confidence in our elections
and this is this bill is voluntary
and this bill um you would raise
um targeted small contributions as
representative porter
um stated there's qualifying
contributions those thresholds are high
so that um
going out and talking to
2 500 voters in for governor
and getting at least a five dollar check
from them
in order to qualify i want to start also
by talking
using a quote from senator former new
hampshire senator warren rudman
he says i challenged my party to return
to its roots
and take up teddy roosevelt's challenge
from more than a century ago
by enacting the only real lasting
solution to our current
campaign finance system known as
citizen-funded elections
citizen-funded elections and public
financing of elections are also
um uh kind of heard
two words that mean the same thing
when we look at how many other states
have some sort of public financing 24
other states have some sort of
public financing five states maine
connecticut hawaii minnesota and arizona
have full public financing of candidates
in other states it's either a county
level office or a municipal level office
public funding
works and has proven to work
to reduce the cost of running for office
to reduce the amount of time candidates
spend fundraising and increase the
amount of time candidates spend talking
to constituents and learning about
issues
it increases the quality and in equal
opportunity in our political system
it also encourages more competition
it reduces the influence of special
interests and out-of-state special
interests
and it also
recognizes that quality legislators
might not be good fundraisers
one of the things that this bill does is
it complies with all federal and
constitutional requirements and upholds
supreme court challenges
to these systems
the main public financing system allows
bold bipartisan legislation
by the public and reduces
industry's objections that's a quote
from maine house speaker
hannah pingree
also i have a quote from janet nepali
former governor of arizona
which i won't read in full it's in my
written testimony but it basically to
summarize means that you can vote your
conscience and you don't have to vote
what industry wants you to
this bill has been introduced before
was first introduced in 2000
and and
narrowly
passed
it has been studied two times with a
formal commission or task force
and
studied extensively
informally
and i in my testimony list a lot of the
other pieces of legislation you have
seen before
and i'm happy to take any questions or
go through the mechanics of the bill
questions represent representative
growing
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
miss zinc for taking my question
does
does this
bill do anything to prevent
candidates from continuing to fund their
campaigns under traditional
methods taking
money as you know from from donors as as
we currently do no
so
how how then
follow up madam chair follow-up uh how
then will this
reduce the impact of
of you know what would be termed dark
money or or private funding of elections
yeah thank you for the question and so
just just to understand these systems
are 100 voluntary it basically puts a
parallel system
in place so you can either choose the
old method of
of raising private contributions
unlimited or you know with who from
whatever
in others and this is how it works
across the country and other states
that have you have these systems maine
for example has a 65
of candidates opt-in to this connecticut
has seen 74 percent of candidates opt in
as these systems are in place more
candidates are opting for this system
of both parties and both parties when
they opt into this system have won
elections
using um these types of system systems
in other states but if you want to use
the current system you can you perf
that's your choice as a candidate
follow up madame follow up
uh
in a in a race such as the governor's
race that is it's a statewide race
obviously
it's pretty hard for a governor
candidate to do enough door knocking to
contact the citizens even within a small
state like new hampshire so it becomes
very very much a
political
organization i mean the organization the
candidates um
you know organization to to advanced
candidate
uh and a media campaign which takes a
lot of money
do you have
any uh record from the states that use
it for example maine
of the success
of the candidates that are using this
are
do
fifty percent of those that use it when
their elections do 10 percent win their
elections how how effective is it in
those candidates succeeding in winning
the race
so i would refer you to anna's testimony
from the main
citizen
for clean elections testimony she does
reference the success rates in maine and
there are reports on on those success
rates i do want to just
say that i believe
deeply that this bill gives candidates
enough money to compete in 2020 governor
sununu raised 1.4 million dollars for
his race and spent that much money in
the election
this bill would give gubernatorial
candidates 1.4 million dollars to run a
competitive race so i believe deeply so
you have
a cap of 420 000 dollars that that a
candidate can use on the citizen
certificates
collecting those from citizens and then
the grant is a million dollars so this
is very competitive and is enough money
it might not be the most i mean we have
seen elections i think governor benson
spent 12 million dollars on his
elections doesn't give you the most
money but it is competitive and enough
money to run
thank you and when you refer to the
testimony that's the writ in the written
package that we received
other questions from the committee
members
representative alexander um thank you
madam chair thank you for taking my
question um mike
my question is um sixty thousand dollars
for a contested
general election race um for executive
council i mean just by looking at cash
on hand of our current counselors like
that seems like a little low to run a
competitive race like do you feel that
this
becomes almost like an incumbent
protection plan by you know restricting
the amount of money
that you know challengers could raise i
know it's voluntary but i guess that's
my question is does it become where the
incumbent's protected because the
challenger has to overcome name id and
other factors before incumbent
protection it actually empowers more
candidates to run for office and the cap
on the executive council race in this
piece of legislation is actually a
hundred and forty four thousand dollars
so the sixty thousand is the grant but
they cannot they can raise up to
eighty four thousand dollars in the
certificate part of the bill so you have
to add both of those numbers for the 144
000 and i do think 144 thousand dollars
is enough to be competitive again not
the most an executive council candidate
has raised but enough
for you to reach out to a fifth of the
state in those races
and i'm happy to share the data and
analysis that we had done on previous
executive council races especially to
get to that 500 number which is the
number of individual contributions and
prior executive council candidates have
gotten to 500 new hampshire voters to
give them contributions so that's again
how we sort of designed that
but it also
doesn't mean that just anyone can
qualify you have to reach out and have
at least 500
people in your district give you
at least five dollars
thank you representative terezian thank
you madam chair thank you for taking the
question missing
um
when you reference the governor's race
if this were to become law wouldn't that
just
create a situation where he would spend
more money
and potentially people would come back
to the taxpayer and want to raise more
money in other words i could see the
spiraling the amount of money spent in
campaigns even
higher you know was it was reported
prior to the governor getting into the
race for a senate that they people were
talking about that being a hundred
million dollar race so it seems like
this has the potential of of making that
um
number get even higher on these races
would you
believe that that's a possibility
so thank you for the question and and i
am outraged by how the cost of campaigns
have been escalating over the last 20
years especially you referenced a
federal race um this only deals with
state races but i think if you look at
the data from maine and arizona and
other states that have these systems the
costs have been more stable
actually
maine has had their program since 1996
and they have voted once to increase the
thresholds of the grants to increase
that
there is a slight part of the main bill
that increases for inflation a little
bit
but state rep races in maine get five
thousand dollars and they did that in
1996 and has stayed stable in that way
so i think if you actually look at some
of the how the track record of how these
systems have worked in other states um
it does actually keeping kind of
campaign spending
um
with that enough threshold and not
escalating out of control
further questions from committee members
representative lane
thank you madam chair thank you ms zinke
um
and i'm sorry i haven't had a chance to
read this but
what about in-kind contributions is
there a restriction on that and is that
covered
yes so in-kind contributions are covered
in the threshold
i believe it's for governor two hundred
and fifty dollars of in kind and for
executive councils 125 dollars of in
kind so if somebody wants to give you
250 dollars worth of pizza you can
accept that but if they want to give you
300 worth of pizza
you that threshold is the same cap
as a cash contribution
may have a follow-up further question um
what about the organizations that have
been mentioned today who come in and
perhaps are not connected to the
campaign but
will run
separate
ads or flyers
is that covered in this or is that
something else that we need to regulate
so independent expenditures and
electioneering communication is outside
the scope of this bill although this
bill does say if you qualify to run
under the public financing system you
disavow
that spending for your candidate it
doesn't prohibit
candidate
independent expenditures for running for
office but i think if you saw in other
states where there's been public
disavows of election year
independent expenditures or pac money
most of the pacs do respect the
candidates wishes if they say please do
not spend money on my pack
but there's not a formal
there's nothing that stops that other
than the candidate publicly saying i
don't want to have money
spent in an independent expenditure way
further questions from committee members
representative alexander um thank you
madam chair you just spurred a question
so i'm i'm thinking like
um
you know in a primary and you have
independent groups that
you don't want them to spend money on
your behalf but maybe a candidate would
host a press conference and be like if
you were gonna spend money
you would spend it here and in this
place and like technically there's a
loophole there about like yeah they can
publicly disavow it and say please don't
spend money but it still happens anyways
so how does this prevent that from
happening
um well thank you for that question and
i do want to
sort of think about how these systems
there is a four twenty five dollar
certificate program
in the city of seattle and in the last
municipal election
there amazon spent over a million
dollars
trying to get candidates elected
that supported amazon's values it didn't
work
this system held up to to a gross
independent expenditure so i think when
you look at those cases of how this has
worked in other states you have seen
that these systems hold up to that kind
of
um and it's not that amazon could have
spent more money in that case there was
just nothing left to buy
they bought all the tv ads they bought
all the radio ads they bought all the
television ads um and there's just
nothing left to buy one political expert
said in in one of the news reporters so
i think when you look at the case
studies of how this works in other
states it actually really holds up to
really big independent expenditure
fights and maine has independent
expenditures that's part of maine's
culture and and it happens with um but i
think in maine voters say i want to be i
want to vote for a candidate that does
not want to take this out of this money
and i think that there is a kind of
incentive to say i want to run clean in
maine which is why they call their
system clean elections
and voters really do respect that kind
of
declaration that the candidates say that
they want to be accountable and one of
the things we call the system a voter
owned system so voters are owning the
system and it's not being funded by
out-of-state
interests and i think that that's really
important that citizens feel that there
there's faith in the process
further questions from committee
thank you for coming
also signed up to speak on this bill is
linda linda bundy
is
good morning madam chair and members of
the house election law committee
my name is linda olsen bundy and i'm
from antrim
since the 2010 supreme court ruling in
citizens united versus fec
wealthy donors and corporations have
exerted undue influence in elections at
all levels from the local through the
national
large amounts of money are contributed
to campaigns which often rely on
misleading attack ads
rather than participation in relevant
political conversations about issues
politicians in new hampshire have
received large donations from hospitals
insurance groups pharmaceutical
corporations the energy industry and
communications companies
these corporations do not have to
publicly disclose their identities so
that citizens do not know who is
supporting and influencing candidates
such a system directly affects who runs
for office and which pieces of
legislation are put into law
so candidates of moderate means cannot
compete against those funded by deep
pockets
the opinions and issues of the wealthy
drive the political agenda
everyday voters hold less weight with
candidates
the solution for this situation is to
reform the funding of campaigns so that
candidates and elected officials are
motivated to serve citizens of new
hampshire rather than big businesses
if enacted
h.b
1423 would be a first step in such
reform
candidates have to meet certain criteria
to be eligible for voter dollars and
registered voters receive four 25 dollar
certificates that they may assign to the
candidates of their choice
participation by candidates and voters
is voluntary
as a result of this reform engagement
between candidates and voters would
increase
the number of financially viable
candidates would grow
and they would have to work to make
voters believe they are the best choice
to receive voter dollars
candidates focus would turn toward their
local constituents instead of toward
corporate donors
of course funding of this system is an
important consideration
the report of the bipartisan 2008
commission to study the feasibility of
public funding of state election
campaigns
has a two-page list of 64 ideas for
sources for public funding
our fellow new england states of maine
and connecticut have well established
public funding systems for state
elections that have been in place for
years
in the interest of decreasing the
influence of big money and increasing
grassroots participation by candidates
and voters in our elections
i ask that you support this bill thank
you for this opportunity thank you
are there any questions for ms bundy
olsen bundy
nice to see you again in an election
event
also signed up to speak on this bill
is
mark mclaughlin
welcome mr mclaughlin
hello my name is
is red on or off there we go i was
thinking red was stopped so it was off
um
mark mclaughlin i'm from north
a lot of people wish government looked
like that if it was read they were safe
but no and this can
that's part of the reason i'm here um so
first of all i want to thank all of you
as representatives um as a voter in new
hampshire the amount of time and effort
as i
get a little more involved feeling the
need to get involved as you see more and
more what's going on i really appreciate
what you guys all of you have done um in
being participants in this process
i want to register support for 1423 not
because i think it's the ideal solution
i'm certainly not for
bureaucratic solutions and big processes
to solve problems that you would hope
didn't come up
[Music]
with something like financing campaigns
but i wouldn't have also thought that
a-rod would make 250 million dollars to
play baseball and i think at some point
as a voter and a citizen
you have to say enough is enough and
move something against it obviously i
think citizens united was an important
piece of
ruling by the supreme court and affected
but i also recognize as a reality
important and how you find
can't
see candidates but i think there has to
be some pushback on how far this has
come
and whether this bill is
a hundred percent
uh tight i think it's goals of more
fairness more transparency
is important i think the fact that it is
voluntary i think that was a great
question by the rep to my left about um
you know what how will this potentially
affected if it is voluntary will it work
we don't know but hopefully it will be
some pushback and there's some evidence
that it's worked in other states and in
other cities
i particularly think
engagement of citizens is important and
part of the reason it's being lost is
this thought that big money and other
interests are running the show and
there's so little i can do
i think everyone in this room is a
testament that you can do something and
i hopefully that will do it i mean i
guess i'm struck by the
person on channel nine that was a rep
from nashua who said that no one showed
up
about the redistricting maps for that
big area
that shocked me
and
this i think would start to build more
citizen engagement i don't have the
source for this but from open democracy
i think that was told that
66 of independents 59 of republicans and
71 percent of democrats when polled
would be more likely to vote for a
candidate who participated
in a public funded program similar to
this and again i don't know the details
of that and i'm not sure if that's in
olivia's report but i think that's
significant
finally there was a thing that i also
saw where there were two-thirds of new
hampshire voters support of public
campaigns
again
i understand reticence about enacting a
program the initial budget ask of one
dollar just to
get it going i think is quite reasonable
and like others i would be willing to
give that one dollar if that's what it
takes
um i think that
what i really would love to see is
campaigns be brought back to the
citizens and having their involvement i
think this is one step that might work
if it didn't then let's revise it and
make it work better but as it goes right
now i'm not willing to throw up my arms
and just say this is how it goes and
that's why i decided to come down here
to just express my opinion and thanks
for your time and i'll take any
questions thank you mr mclaughlin any
questions from committee members
i'm seeing none
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
representative murhead
thank you madam chair um representative
muirhead i make you take the witness
seat oh okay
glad to
thank you madam chair um
and thank you to my colleagues on the
election law committee for um
trying to wrap your minds around this
this bill and this idea i think it's
really cool i'd want to describe it
super briefly and how it would operate
there are basically three steps to the
bill and operation the first one would
be that candidates would try to qualify
by collecting lots of small donations
they have to collect a whole lot of
small donations
almost five dollars
and once
they
qualify
then they're able to ask citizens for
the 25 certificates four of which are
given to every voter in the state
and they're eligible to receive those
certificates up to a certain limit
and in the third step of its operation
the winners of primaries would receive
um a tranche of money immediately from
the public financing fund
so candidates for the gubernatorial
election would receive a million dollars
as soon as they won the primary because
the turnaround from the primary to the
general election is so short in our
current calendar
so those are the three steps
qualify
and then you have to really work hard to
qualify a lot of candidates who want to
be governor a lot of people want to be
executive counselors would never qualify
you got to get a lot of small donations
to qualify
then once you qualify you can ask people
for those
for those certificates and the third
thing if you win the primary you get an
extra bunch of money that you that
allows you to immediately run
um a viable campaign of course as all of
you know
the the nature of of of money in in
elections is such that every extra
dollar is is extra valuable up to a
certain point and then the utility of
each dollar kind of peaks
it flattens out it diminishes
at a certain point if you spend 100
million dollars on a senate campaign it
approaches zero it probably goes
negative every extra dollar of
expenditure is probably harming your
campaign after a while
so this is enough money to get people to
the point where they can run viable
campaigns one point i think is worth
knowing is that candidates can collect
private donations throughout the entire
campaign season there is no limit to
that ex to the number of donations
there's just a limit to the amount they
can't collect more than 250 check from
any one individual if you're running for
governor
but you can do it while you're
collecting certificates in the general
election you can keep campaign here's
the key 90 of the donations have to come
from in-state donors
and that i think is the great thing
about this bill yesterday somebody
called me while i was working somebody
running for governor in another state of
course you know they want my money i say
you call the wrong guy i don't have any
money and why are you talking to me i'm
not in your state you know you shouldn't
be responsive to me i'm not your
constituent i'll never be your
constituent this is what's wrong with
our system that you're calling people
all over the country begging for money
and it's not tuning you in to the to the
voters whom you will represent
i'd love to have
uh you know a political system where a
certain kind of great citizen could
realistically aspire to be the governor
of the state where you know plow driver
who's a volunteer firefighter who served
on the select board who's a coach who
knows their town
and who volunteers for everything and
has done so for years and years assault
of the earth who knows their region who
knows this state can realistically
aspire to be the governor of the state
i'd love to see something like that be
our governor even though they're not
connected to networks of rich lawyers
who give
you know accustomed to writing checks to
candidates and they're not a cousin they
haven't made promises to unions and they
just aren't part of the power elite
um and and i think that this that this
bill would actually make that possible
with olivia zinc i've worked through the
potential cost of this bill if it were
in full operation
and i'm happy to talk about that
i can just
briefly point to this that if there were
contested if lots of people ran the
primaries and lots of people qualified
again not easy to qualify because you
need so many small donations from
in-state donors to do that but if lots
of people did it and if every election
every executive council district and the
governors were contested
and three people were running for
governor that kind of thing we we see
we've gone line by line by line three to
six million dollars per campaign season
a lot of money but that's all the money
it takes for voters to own elections and
and that's now this appropriation this
bill just donates one dollar the idea
being
the this i this idea i think to work has
to come from both parties it has to be
initiated in a in a broad bipartisan way
people have to understand that people
have to like the idea
and then the taxpayers will be
and i think their representatives will
be okay with funding it so this bill is
about
is about transmitting the idea and about
about arguing for the underlying concept
thank you very kindly
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative mirad for taking my
question
so you you went through three steps and
i i have
you know
getting a better understanding of step
one and two of of how they
you know that collect a bunch of small
donations and then the qualified
candidate
received some the certificates during
the
campaign the primary campaign but at
after the candidate wins the primary you
said they get a large sum of money a
large lump of money
where does that large lump of money come
from how is that raised it comes from
exactly the same fund that finances the
25 certificates so there's a voter
elections fund
that's created
this bill only contributes one dollar to
that fund which is not certain not not
sufficient
the bill
and
right now that fund would be funded
through fines on people who violate
election laws and so forth donations and
to the one dollar but ultimately you
would need a general appropriation
you follow up madam chair follow up so
so the
the funding
is not coming from donations from
individuals but ultimately it will come
from the state that's correct and those
fo what every voter in the state gets
are four twenty five dollar certificates
they don't have to come up with a
hundred dollars themselves most voters
don't have a hundred dollars they could
give to candidates so they're getting a
certificate that's financed from the
voter election fund
i.e the state yes
thank you
further questions representative
alexander um thank you madam chair
um thank you representative has there
been any thought of making this a
constitutional amendment um and i guess
my question is if this is so popular and
widely
um you know wanted by you know all
parties based on what we just heard has
there been any thought of just turning
this into a cacr instead
so i actually what i just said and this
is my opinion is that in order to as i
foresee it to for something
whether it does
elicit that kind of broad and deep
support um from from the whole
population there's a further question i
haven't done the work to i think we're
trying to convince people of the idea
right now and bring that to push i
actually don't agree with vi with with
amending the constitution every time you
have a good idea so i think i'd be very
reluctant to go down that route
further questions representative hayward
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the question um i'd like to go
back to your
assessment about how this would improve
the
the transparency
and in full disclosure i
i mean i i work in the state of maine so
with a law
similar has already been described i
would look
not at
how well that law worked i would look at
various out-of-state monies spent
uh
i mean the senatorial election
last last time around was now you're
diminishing returns
aspect i'm
interested
in that
thing
yes sir thank you we i mean the idea um
and again i think it's it's in fact
illegal to to to say that independent
expenditures can't be made so this bill
can't say that although i think the
disavowal function
apparently is quite effective
this bill aims to give candidates for
the executive council and for the
governor a sufficient amount of money to
run a viable campaign
if they can show
that they have real support
from voters of new hampshire who in the
initial stage are willing to write them
a five dollar check in large numbers
and and so it's it's not as i said meant
to to give every candidate the maximum
amount that that they might conceivably
spend or wish to have just enough to
have a
viable campaign
thank you for when you proceeded to make
the argument
meant that at a certain point a
contribution to a candidate has a
negative impact
all right um and then signed up to speak
on this bill is ciao kelly
thank you madam chair and thank you the
election members
um
i'm speaking here to
oppose the bill 1423
fna
um
i didn't i couldn't read the whole
details of all this bill but from the
summary of this and from listening to
all the previous um
uh
testimonies
the idea of level the playing field for
all the candidates sounds wonderful
and i see a lot of candidates good
candidates out there working hard just
to like fundraising
to do good for the public and i
understand about the gap
and this level of playing field also
reminded me of the communist system of
everybody had to be the same
now it's not based on performance it's
based on
how we feel that people
should be on the equal level it doesn't
matter your level of performance but it
makes me feel good that you're on the
same level of playing field and it's all
about the money
and as of right now this is about
uh the um
the uh establish a voter owned
election commission to admit administer
the fund
i don't even owe my vote right now that
is what i feel like and see for myself
after november 3rd election 2020 i don't
even owe my vote
because there's no way
the whole state of new hampshire
and republicans for the whole state yet
we lost the pharaoh
and people complained up to the
attorney general
to have
uh you know take a look at the new
hampshire elections
and they didn't go through uh the
attorney general
it had to take uh sb 43
to get us to have a
a forensic audit for winning him thank
you for your testimony here today but
i'm going to ask you to speak to the
bill that we have before us okay
so i oppose this because and he is
talking about the fund
if there's mismanagement of the fund is
go to the attorney general but the
attorney general doesn't do their job so
what do we do
so we don't need another big problem
for the the voters
to manage and go through all these legal
process that's not gonna work
so you know please
oppose this bill thank you for your time
thank you for testifying any questions
for miss kelly
i'm seeing none
thanks thank you
that is the last pink card i have for
people indicating that they are
interested in speaking to this bill is
there anybody here who would
like to offer further testimony on house
bill 1423
i'm seeing none
there was an electronic sign up for this
bill
83 person signed up electronically in
support of the bill five signed up
in opposition thank you representative
terozian
for persons who are in attendance today
at the state house we have two people
signed up in favor of it and three
signed up against it
with that that concludes our hearing on
our next hearing today
is
hb 1542
hb 1542 the prime sponsor is
representative abramson representative
abramson contacted me this morning that
he was not going to be able to make it
into the state house today unexpectedly
and i indicated that i would have
someone else introduce his bill so our
new official designated bill introducer
for when sponsor is not here
representative hayward
is now with us to introduce hb 1542.
thank you representative hayward thank
you madam chair i hope i'm here as a
pinch hitter not as a designated hitter
so i'm going to introduce the hb 1542 fn
the it's an act relative to
documentation required to prove a
voter's eligibility to vote now if you
look at the analysis part it's not
exactly correct because
um it's actually uh concerning
provisional ballots and the
qualification for provisional ballots
so
right subject to your questions
thank you representative hayward
uh i have
david scanlon secretary of state also
signed up to speak in regards to this
bill hb 1542
welcome
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee i'm acting secretary of
state
david scanlon and i really haven't had
the opportunity
to address you a little bit since i took
the oath of office a little over a week
ago
seems like a month
um but things are going smoothly and and
i look forward to working with you uh
you should all know that bill gardner is
in good health
he's enjoying some time off and i expect
that you know he will be around so um
you know he hasn't gone too far away and
i think that's a good thing
before i get started i would like to
introduce some of the staff that we have
i think it's a good idea that we start
involving
more people in our department that have
expertise in elections get them used to
the legislative process
testifying and also being available to
answer your questions
and being a resource so i think you've
already seen trisha pietsu who is our
elections director
former city clerk of nashua
and next to her is katie gargano
working closely with tricia in the hava
office former city clerk of the town of
franklin
and then also sitting behind me is
patty lovejoy who many of you know as a
former legislator
uh we're bringing patty on as
the part-time senior deputy secretary of
state
uh filling the position that bob ambrose
had
earlier patti has a lot of experience
doing recounts
did a fantastic job
in that area
served on the finance committee when she
was in the house and has a background in
accounting which i think that we will
find very helpful in the department
so they're all available to you
if the need arises and of course i am as
well just
come over and see me or call me anytime
um
on house bill 1542
we opposed the bill as written
um
the constitution our state constitution
is clear that ballots have to be counted
that are cast have to be counted on the
day of the election
and we also have an exemption
from the national voter registration act
because we have
same-day voter registration that
exemption
allows us
currently not to have to engage with in
provisional ballots
which other states that
uh they're subject to the national voter
registration act have to have
i think the
the general tenor of the bill trying to
create checks and balances in the
process to make sure that voters are
adequately qualified is certainly a fair
discussion to have
however this particular bill has some
pretty significant problems
that i think would land us in court very
quickly and i think it would be very
difficult to defend
some of the provisions that are in here
and just to give you some examples
um in section three of the bill i'm
sorry section two of the bill
um there's a provision and the statute
currently
that allows
for a voter to be recognized
by firsthand knowledge
by
an election official in the polling
place
as to their identity
and that
that recognition
is the same as the person having
a valid form of id to accept the ballot
the language in this bill would allow
and there is there is currently a
provision in the statute that allows any
other voter in the polling place
to challenge a voter who's recognized by
an election official
and that voter can proceed to vote if
they fill out a challenged voter
affidavit
this provision would require that a
voter who is challenged by being
recognized by an election official would
automatically then have to fill out
a provisional ballot
that would that could create a situation
where a voter could simply hang on the
polling place and wait for voters
obtaining their ballot being recognized
to simply challenge them
and forcing a provisional ballot on that
person
the person would then have to go home
and get their credentials and then come
back to the polling place
in section four
see your section four
section four of the bill actually deals
with a provision
that allows a voter to go into the town
clerk's office prior to the day of the
election
to request an absentee ballot and in the
process of requesting the absentee
ballot uh
they can either prevent that they can
either present
uh their qualifications either driver's
license or whatever
to prove their identity
or sign a
challenged voter affidavit
to have their ballot automatically uh
verified on the day of the election
it's a process
the absentee voting process is generally
different than voting by official ballot
on the day of the election
the qualifications are different you
know a voter who's on the checklist
can make application to the clerk and
receive their absentee ballot
uh and vote on it it can be challenged
on the day of the election when the
ballots are being processed
um
but this would require
uh
it would it would offer as an
alternative a voter to cast a
provisional ballot prior to the election
uh when they're doing that in the
clerk's office
it it raises another issue uh related to
is it appropriate for a provisional
ballot to be offered to a voter prior to
election day
that's not clear in the statute
and my sense is that provisional ballots
are something that should be offered on
the day of the election
if a voter cannot there's unable to fill
out a just a regular official ballot
and then there are provisions further
down in section
six
roman numeral ii would a plow would have
would
require that a unique identifier be
placed on a
provisional ballot
that could be problematic in how it's
done
and then roman numeral six
is a requirement that
anyone any voter who votes by a
provisional ballot would be required to
come back before the polls close
with their identification
in order to be able to have their vote
counted
and that may not be enough time and i
suspect that the courts would have a
real problem with that
currently those states that engage in
provisional ballots issue them on the
day of the election
and the voter has a period of time after
the election to be able to
show their qualifications or be verified
by election officials to have their vote
count
i'll stop there madam chair and i'd be
happy to try and answer any questions
thank you secretary scanlon it does make
it a little more problematic when the
sponsor's not here so we don't have the
entire intent
any questions from committee members
for secretary scanlan on
hb 1542
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill is
ciao kelly
thank you madam chair
um
yeah i'm speaking to support bill 1542
fn
um i've been to a lot i've been to a lot
of elections
and
recounts
and audit
and i see that many recounts they have a
very small margin
between the winner
and the loser
so
this bills is important
to determine if those votes that casted
that day was real or not
because from my understanding is that
the follow-up to make sure that those
uh paperwork affidavit people sign that
they could go to jail if they lie in all
that
and not being enforced
so and the election officials
are not allowed to do anything about
that so people can just showed up
without paperwork and just promise
something inside and no one follow up on
it
just like you buy with no teeth
and those margins
of the winning and the losing is very
critical to the voice of freedom
and rice and so many constitutional
rights of the whole state of new
hampshire
so um i hear that um
mr skilling was saying earlier about
it's conflicting with that one-day
same-day registration
it's there
and from what i hear on the ground a lot
is that we should get rid of that same
day registration
that is a big problem in our state
the college students from all over the
places they just sign in
and vote thank you i understand that but
if you could stick to 1542 that would be
great yes so please support this bill
and um you know so we need to check and
make sure
that people are qualified
to vote
you go to the bank and you want to take
out your money you have to show your id
you go to vote you want to take away my
freedom you need to show id too
with your vote not with just a promise
so thank you so much please support this
bill thank you
also signed up to speak on this bill
sorry does anybody have any questions
i'm not seeing any so thanks
also signed up to speak on this bill is
russon chester
thank you madam chair thank you
committee members
um
i am here in support of this bill
i
sure you folks have heard
plenty about how many people in the
state of new hampshire
are concerned with our voting rights and
what's been going on during elections
i'm going to speak a little more
personally today with regards to what i
saw occurring in my hometown what i saw
occurring in my hometown is that the
same day registration
um was
a line i
took 18 different people i volunteered
to pick up people and take them in to
vote
during those 18 well i had 19 trips
because i voted by myself before that so
during that 19 trips the line for
same-day registration and for for um
for
not having appropriate voter id
was longer than any of the lines to just
get your ballot to vote that's a problem
we have one voting
place where in my town um i saw more
than 25 percent
on in every occasion i went around that
parking lot and i took us i took a a a
count on how many out of state cars that
i saw at my polling page place and at no
point was it lower than 25 percent
the last issue was i saw on more than
one of my 19 trips
black sprinter vans with multiple people
getting out of them going into my
polling place and signing up for same
day register voter registration
the fact that
our laws our voting laws are so
loosey-goosey is a shambles um
this will provide to tighten it up a
little bit more it's it may not be
as
as tight as it should be but the bottom
line is the right to vote should be it's
a right but with that comes
responsibilities and the fact that we
allow people to just
manage this privilege and this right the
way we do is a travesty so that being
said i hope you will
really look at this as well as some of
the other election
voting
bills that are before you and
i hope that you can support this bill
thank you for your testimony and i
believe your town is bedford is that
right that's correct okay because you
referenced it a couple of times that's
correct and i did and and for the record
i did um i did bring
my concerns to the attention
um there were other concerns as well but
it didn't relate to this bill
so i'm not speaking on it
but i did bring it to the attention of
my town
as well as the
new hampshire gop and
it was on fell on deaf ears thank you
questions from committee members
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you madam chair
did you contact the attorney general's
office i did
and did you follow up uh did you receive
a response
i
received a response saying that my
response had been received and it would
be reviewed that's all i ever received
they are full of lawyers over there
there you go
any further questions
i'm not seeing any thanks for coming
thank you
that is the last pink card i have on hb
1542 is there anybody else here who
would like to speak to hb
i'm not seeing anybody and
representative terozian has
gone to bring me the
sign up for uh positions on 1542 today
there was a lineup
uh excuse me electronic signup i don't
know where i got lineup
electronic signup we had 11 people sign
up in support of this bill 119 sign
electronically in opposition to the bill
one
person online was neutral
and here in the legislative office
building today signing up on the blue
sheet we have four people signed up in
favor of the bill
that concludes the public hearing on hb
1542 it is noon the committee is now on
lunch recess until one o'clock when we
will take up hb 10 10. thank you very
much everybody
i have no idea
good afternoon everyone
this is the afternoon session of the new
hampshire house election law committee
we are conducting public hearings today
the first public hearing scheduled for
the afternoon at one o'clock and
i'm okay by that clock i think
um
is
hb 1010 requiring municipal voter
history to make it to be made accessible
in the statewide centralized voter
registration database uh the primary
sponsor is representative sweeney who is
unavailable today here to introduce the
bill is representative barry welcome
representative barry thank you madam
chairman and once again i am the new
representative sweeney i'm smarter and
better looking
um
the uh i i have to uh the the bill that
i introduced represented sweden this
morning i misspoke on um when i said
that the sec the language is in the
wrong section i was actually referring
to this bill um 110. um what this bill
does is it fixes a a unintentional
loophole where the municipal voter
history is not included in the statewide
file that's available for purchase for
certain entities in the state
um it is entirely that as a housekeeping
bill we will have it by we mean him
because i'm not on the bill there will
be an amendment that comes forward that
moves us i believe to section four of
this rsa to address the issue of it
being in the wrong section but the the
intent you know i think we can still
have
a good hearing on the the intent and the
purpose um but that
legislative oversight on his end i will
not take credit for his mistake um
is is already been notified and already
been addressed i think actually the
secretary of state's office flagged it
for us so hat tip to them
thank you
questions for representative barry
representative growing representative
barry uh your earlier comments about uh
being smarter and better looking is that
an opinion or a research factor i would
say it's uh i believe the office of the
research office did confirm that
no further questions manager all right
any other questions for representative
barry does
is there anybody here from the secretary
of state's office who's going to take a
position on the addition of this
information
okay um
which means of course she knows she's
going to go get a pink card
you already did your pink card any other
questions for representative barry
representative tarosian
thank you madam chair thank you
representative barry
so just looking at the fiscal note on
this it says it is a um
maybe there isn't one on this one never
mind maybe i got ahead of myself on
another bill correct there shouldn't be
a fiscal note on this because the
information is already in the statewide
database
um my understanding is that it is so
it's just a matter of making it
available
okay
thank you
any other questions for representative
barry
see none
thank you
all right it's
tricia welcome
just pass that along members thank you
good afternoon madam chair and honorable
members of the election law committee my
name is trisha pietso i'm with the
secretary of state's office
currently relative to house bill 1010
and the amendment that's going to be
forthcoming as representative barry
noted currently certain entities like
the state parties those individuals that
are finally for office can obtain from
us election history from the secretary
of state plus the
voter list of registered voters
but the way that the law currently reads
is that they're only allowed to receive
the past two years state elections what
this would only modify is to include in
all the municipal elections that
currently the cities and towns currently
enter the history into the system so it
would just be an addition to a move just
giving them a state history
of all those that have voted in the past
two years would also provide them the
municipal history now
most some municipal history would be a
two-year period because you have towns
that have local elections every year you
have a couple cities that do have local
elections each year as well but most
cities have it biennial so with that i
would be happy to take any questions
that the canadian may have
questions from the committee
i have a question
there was a comment made about the
fiscal note
there is a fiscal note to do some
initial programming changes but is that
your understanding of what it would be
limited to the the actual
um
providing of the information and how
it's done is currently in place that is
correct okay
representative terezian thank you madam
chair thank you man for taking the
question
yes there is a fiscal note as is the
chair indicated um which looks like it's
a haver
funded
item so does that mean federal money
will pay for that there's a grant for
that
it's a possibility it depends with our
vendor that we currently have if they
were to
we have so many hours of free service
for them for a year so if we could put
it within that it would be within that
if we don't have any other ongoing
projects otherwise than that it would be
through our health america vote act
funds
follow-up representative so in either
event there would be no additional cost
to new hampshire taxpayer then is that
correct that is correct thank you
further questions
seeing none thank you very much you're
very welcome is there anybody else here
who'd like to speak on hb 10 10
i'm not seeing anybody and i don't have
any other pink cards so if i can have
the blue sheet for that we did have
remote
um
testimony in support or against on this
bill
six people signed in remotely five
signed in in support of it and one
person signed in
in opposition
and here today in the legislative office
building registering an opinion but not
speaking we had three people sign up and
they were all in favor
that concludes the hearing on hb 1010
our next hearing is 1442
and that is scheduled for 1 30 so the
committee is in recess for 15 minutes
okay it is 1 30 sort of here in the
election law committee new hampshire
house
it is january 19th
and scheduled for hearing at 1 30 is hb
1442.
this is relative to access to election
and voter information
and the prime sponsor is with us here
today welcome thank you madam chair and
thank you committee um so my name is
representative manny espithia i'll be
speaking on hb
1442 now the original version of the
bill what you have in front of you um is
that bill
specifically talks about voter
checklists i have brought to you commit
uh committee amen or sorry an amendment
an unapproved amendment and this would
this amendment would replace the bill
and actually
uh be more towards what i
what the intent of the of my bill was
which is
basically providing information for
election instructions and ballot
uh
and ballots to be printed in uh up to
three different languages including
english
what would trigger that is if somebody
if a district had a population of people
that spoke
more than uh three percent if three
percent three percent of the people in
that district
spoke a different language
um so if you
for example in a city like nashua where
the second highest language
spoken is spanish and about nine percent
of people of residents in
nashville speak spanish
this would then trigger trigger that it
would trigger the the clerk to reach out
to the secretary of state um to let them
know if uh that that information be
provided in
that language being spanish right now um
so this is you know i think our
communities are changing our state is
becoming much more diverse
with
racially and ethically diverse uh we
have people who are coming in with you
know speaking different languages
and so we want to make sure that they
have the right access to
uh to election materials um and i will
say you know while it is you know while
it would be good you know everyone speak
english i think you know i think back to
not just my own but many people who
you know who who i've grown up with who
i and who are friends to me who've told
me you know i've been you know i've been
trans they've been translators when they
were 10 years old for their parents
at medical appointments um you know they
are citizens but they still don't have
the maximum proficiency of the language
so you know one of the highest honors we
get to do as you know as american
citizens is we get the chance to vote um
and while
you know ten-year-old manny would have
loved to have followed his parents since
the voting booth and told them all right
this is you know this is this means uh
circle one box here or circle or fill in
one block here like you know i think
having that information in their native
language would go a long way to making
sure that you know we
that we provide that that we and
everybody gets a chance to vote and you
know that language isn't a barrier for
them so
i'm hoping that y'all take a seriously
look a serious look at the amendment um
which is 2022-01608
uh it's been handed out to you and i'm
hoping that you know y'all are able to
pass the amendment so that it would be
you know attached to the bill um
otherwise the bill on its own is
you know you'll probably replace headers
and change those into different
languages but it's not as uh so the
amendment really is kind of the
important part of the bill so with that
you know i'm i'm happy to take any
questions that the committee has
questions from committee members
representative alexander thank you madam
chair just procedurally am i allowed to
ask questions about the amendment even
though it hasn't yes i'm going to allow
questions we've i am i am going to
support sponsors who bring in amendments
that are relevant to the bill for the
initial public hearing even though i
understand it has been not been noticed
because i think it makes it easier for
the public and this in fact is sort of a
major change it would make no sense to
be asking questions about the original
bill and i will also assume that i will
have a
uh committee member that is willing to
introduce the amendment at the executive
session on this and so those are the
assumptions i'm making when we go
forward on that
um so yes proceed thank you madam chair
and thank you representative um
so i have two questions if that's okay
my first question is
um i was a spanish major like i speak
spanish
but spanish isn't my primary language so
um i'm looking at the amendment and
there's nothing in here that says that
if three percent or more it's their
primary language or if it's just three
percent speak that language so can you
can you clarify that for me yeah we
would determine it through the census um
and looking at census data they gather
that information of like primary
languages spoken so i think we would you
know i would base this on census
information which we just you know we
just finished the 2020 census so we
should have that information
okay and then my follow-up is um
i'm looking at the language and there's
nothing in here that says the ballot or
voted checklist has to be in english
must be in english
uh that the voter checklist has meaning
the
the language changes here if if the
three languages in a municipality the
top three are not english oh yeah um
what would happen with this legislation
like it doesn't always have to be in
english like at least um that's a good
question um
well i'm just being forced no no no no
it's just funny because i think really
forward-looking yeah i think like back
in the day like i think you would have
made a really good argument for like
having the ballot in french for example
because we did have a strong french
canadian background like you know i
think it's waned out unfortunately and
you know i appreciate the their their
contributions to to our great state um
but that is
you know i i think that is a valid
question i think um
i don't i mean i don't foresee that
happening in the next
decade or even century but i'm hoping um
i mean that's why it says includes
english so
but i don't think that's i don't think
that'll be an issue but it could be
wrong
further questions from committee members
representative hayward
now thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the question um
headers directions
those appear to be fairly simple
to execute
um but uh warn articles
uh and
charter
city charter sorts of uh things that
how do you uh
feel that that'll be approached
yeah thank you for the question um i
believe that we can that
you know we can find information to have
it translated um there are professional
translators out there who
who we can seek out i don't think it
would be a high cost
and i think you know that would be
something that which is triggered if
there was a population that's three
percent or more so you know if there
isn't then there's no need to worry
about that um but if there is i think
you know that's why we try to do it 90
days before the election so we try to
give ourselves some time so that we can
find the right translators and make sure
that it gets you know it gets done in a
timely fashion so
further questions from the committee
representative barry
so would you be open to an amendment
about this about um
because we talked about primary
languages but there's many you know i
grew up in
houston which
there's it was actually the most diverse
city in the country a lot of people
don't know that
um obviously with the large hispanic
population
um
the
it doesn't say in here pr it says
primary language but there's depends
people are bilingual will we be counting
people
that are bilingual in this or is just
any language other than english because
it could be you see what i'm saying it
could be unnecessary if someone speaks
english and spanish right we'd be
counting them i think right currently
when they're not they wouldn't
necessarily need to be counted because
they speak english right
so
um i mean i think it's sorry i think you
know we're looking at the primary
language um and like i said that number
of nine percent of spanish speakers is
primary language in nashua um which is a
high number i'm like that i'm like damn
how do you sorry excuse my language i
apologize for using that word um but how
do you function you know making sure
that's your only language and then i
remember i'm like oh because you have a
10 year old son or 10 year old daughter
like myself that's translating your
information for your parents um but
i mean i i mean the bill is now with you
all so if y'all are are open to amending
it that's you know
that's that's the all
further questions from committee members
representative alexander thank you madam
chair just one more um so the
their specific language that go on town
warrant articles um approved language um
would that cost to hire the translator
be picked up by the state or would the
municipality need to hire the translator
and
how would that language like it's very
specific language that's approved so um
how would you
how would you envision this bill working
yeah dra language
that's a good question i think you know
it goes down to the
if it's a war article i think you know
we have professional translators
who would who would do like you know
it's their job to do professional
translations and they do it for illegal
you know like there are legal
professions that use these these these
services so i think you know i would
trust them
to do the best they can i think the cost
would probably go up
would probably be
with the secretary of state but i can't
you know i can't be certain i like you
know like i can't
um so i think that's probably something
that would probably have to be like do a
little bit of work on representative
barry um so i don't i don't share the
concern about finding translators i
think we're going to be able to find
plenty of people to do that um probably
some that would even do it for free
um
on the your amendment here deals with
the printing of the ballot um to go you
know i represent manchester we have
charter amendments on occasion those
charter amendments can be very long um
and the reason i'm bringing that up is
you know i know from my time studying
spanish that um the length of one
language is not always the length of
another um and that could create spatial
issues on the ballot right so if you've
got you know the compute the the ocr
readers reads you know it's looking for
a fill-in at this point on the sheet and
it uses the black bars on the side as a
guiding point to figure out where that
is
if that moves is that and maybe this is
the question for the secondary states to
be fair this baby beyond you so
would that if that moves that
i'm just wondering if they factor that
into the fiscal note because if it moves
that bubble
now we're talking about a new ballot
arguably going into a different machine
um so i just think we need to take into
consideration those things but i don't
i'm trying to get to that point which is
would it possibly move that would that
have a fiscal note and you may not be
able to answer that and maybe a question
for the secretary of state's office to
be fair no i think that's i think it's a
really valid question um
and i think you know where
other states already have
some sort of you know
like have ballots translated in other
from in other languages
you know i think we can pick up some
best practices i mean
texas i'm sure there are like they print
some some of the places print out
ballots in different languages because
they just at that point you're hitting
uh
you're hit you're hitting a voting
rights act like you know threshold
so um so they're required to by law and
so i think
you know we can definitely look at best
practices from other states to see uh to
see how they're doing it and whether or
not you know you have to replace you
know go about doing what you're what you
talked about
further questions representative
tarosian
thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking the question i
think i heard you say in testimony that
um currently about nine percent of the
national population is spanish-speaking
um what kind of help is available now
for for
citizens when they go to vote is there
um
translators or is there um
some kind of help with the community
groups and so forth thank you for the
question that's a really that's a really
good question so
it depends it really depends on what
voting location you're at you know i
think
that in my district specifically they
typically i know that the the city clerk
works really hard to try to get
folks who speak you know who speak their
uh that language in that district's
being so being spanish like they are and
sometimes even portuguese they get
somebody who speaks that language to try
to be there at the at the polling
location
um
but i've seen it in other polling
locations where they don't have somebody
who speaks that language and it becomes
really difficult especially when it
comes to a you know a new registrant if
somebody's registering for the first
time maybe they just became a citizen
um so it's you know it's it really
ranges
it's so it's not a uniform process it's
really kind of
at the discretion of the city you know
of the town or city clerk
thank you further questions
with the committee's indulgence i have a
couple of comments and questions because
i and i'm throwing this out there to see
if there's interest and whether or not
somebody wants to do a further amendment
um first of all i
i guess i could do a would you believe
but i i would you believe i might
disagree with the fact that translators
might be an issue because i can tell you
from a court perspective when we have
hearings and we need a translator even
in
a fairly common language it is quite dif
it is not easy to get those translators
as a matter of fact i might argue it was
easier to get them 15 years ago than it
is now
and in that regards
and i'm this is hypothetical the court
translators are certified and they are
sworn under oath when you use them
so i don't understand how you would use
just have people volunteering services
to do certification without some sort of
um
some sort of way to assure that the
translation was correct
i do think that this is a fiscal note
but i think my guess is and somebody
from the secretary of state's office
might come back i suspect it would be
one of those that would say
undeterminable
because
um there is no way currently of
forecasting and
and that local ballots for your local
election are the responsibilities of our
municipality so i can see the secretary
of state's office arguing that if
there's a translation requirement the
municipality would need to assume the
cost
of that because the secretary of state's
office is not involved in those local
ballot preparations
finally i do actually have a question
um how did you come up with the three
percent because it's my understanding
that the federal law voting rights act
actually kicks in for a language
requirement at five percent
so could you explain why it is different
so
i i can't believe all those things first
um
thank you for indulging me i can't
believe i can't believe because you're
you're right i think with like you know
especially with language that
you know you want to get it right on
these translations you don't want
something to you know to be lost
so to speak lost in translation but you
don't want meaning to be lost so getting
certified folks
it can be tough
so um
so i can't believe that in terms of the
three percent i think
you know i used it as as just kind of a
you know a lower threshold but not
something where it's like you know one
percent or two percent i think i thought
three percent was just a little bit was
just the right size for it i do think
you know our our population is changing
and i want to make sure that we that we
change like you know that we are trying
to accommodate for them as well um
but and you know i don't think and it
really ranges on the types of
communities so you know i don't there
are certain parts of the state where i'm
like i don't know if we're ever gonna
need this um but you never know um and
that's that's part of the exciting part
but the three percent i think is just
slightly below
the federal level and and so that's why
i was one with the three percent thank
you further questions
representative prudhomme o'brien
thank you madam chair and thank you for
coming here today i have a question
about that nine percent that i've been
thinking of and i apologize if it's
already been answered nine what's the
nine percent the nine percent uh
population of nashua that speaks spanish
of that or is it nine percent maybe it's
the entirety but of that
how what is the percentage of people
that speak spanish
exclusively and live their
entire life only speaking spanish right
i i don't know off the top uh thank you
for the question i don't know off the
top of my head um and you probably have
to really delve deep into it
um
i mean it's it's it really depends i
mean i have family members who or i
should not use my own personal anecdotal
evidence so there are folks out there
who will you know who go on and don't
ever feel the need to change you know to
learn the english language because they
are live in an enclave and it's you know
all the services are provided for them
in that language because they're
surrounded by it
uh that's not to say that like you know
that there are communities in in new
hampshire that are like that are that
you know uniform where you could
go about and not have to speak like
english
um but i will say i think you know i
think folks try to make the effort uh to
speak to learn english um
i mean
if like once again now i will go in and
like that anecdotally i think they're
like growing up i remember seeing these
ads for for this translation service
called ingles
which means english without barriers and
like if you ever tell a latino kid about
inglesi marreras they're like boom like
it'll it'll like set off like trigger be
like oh my god i remember those
commercials um but like there is you
know there's a concerted effort to like
try to learn um try to learn english try
to assimilate and try to
be a part of their community i but you
know i think
there it it takes time to learn english
it's not an easy language to learn um
and we are we're lucky because we get to
spend you know k through 12 learning it
um but i and that's not to say uh
spanish is any easier but i think that
you know i think i think people new
americans and immigrants do try to make
a concerted effort to learn english
i just want to make sure that by the
time you know if they're in the middle
of that process that they can get to
vote
and that they in a language that they
feel comfortable in
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on
1442 is ruth and chester
thank you for allowing me to speak today
um on the onset of this
i i did not i haven't seen the amendment
so i was going based on the original
um
1442. with just including the
supervisors checklist but um a couple of
things that i have concerns about
is the fact that this information on
what three languages that we're going to
choose
is actually going to be taken by the
census figures the united states census
figures include citizens non-citizens
legal residents non-citizen long-term
visitors and undocumented immigrants
so in that by itself
it's we
only
citizens are allowed to vote
but we're going to take non-citizen
information
and determine what language should be on
our ballots that's a problem for me
one of the things that
the town of bedford does very well
is that they have
the instructions for the ballots the
ballots are all in english but the
instructions on how to complete a ballot
and how to go through the process any
warrant articles or anything like that
the instructions themselves are
available in every language
written
so this solves the problem as
the committee chair mentioned with
regards to translators i worked with a
minority population for a long time and
translators are not only hard to find
but they're extremely expensive
the other thing is translators come with
their own
ideas and ideals so
unless it's a unless it's a
certified translator you don't know what
that translator is telling the
prospective voter um so that's a problem
they are also very expensive
um
it only it would only be one day an
election cycle but
by how many how um
how many towns and municipalities
the other thing with regards to this is
that
personally the one thing i like about
this bill is that it would create
problems on the ballot and we'd have to
go to hand count
personally
so that's just a little aside um
there was something else
uh
i think that i'll just i'll just end
with that and but like i said my biggest
issue with that is is if we're going to
generate what generate um
what languages we use from census
information i think that's
not appropriate
thank you thank you any questions
not seeing any
thanks also signed up to speak on this
is chow kelly
thank you madam chair um so i would like
if
you could go to the website
doj.nh.gov
and look on it
and the first thing you see
is the flag
on this website
is china's flag
[Music]
so back to your question about
is english going to be official on this
checklist that is my question too
because i don't see anywhere on this
department of justice website the
american flag
but we see the china flag on it
besides french
uh france and um
other languages i don't i don't
recognize the flag
and i only discovered this during the
windham audit
like what is china flex doing here this
is new hampshire website
and i put it on facebook and everybody's
like whoa
they call the
it hasn't been fixed so if this coming
to law
is all the towns in new hampshire gonna
have
certain flags like this show up on their
their website
so i feel like i'm in china
looking at this website we're not in new
hampshire anymore that's one problem
that i have with this bill
second
is as you said about the cost
it doesn't matter who pay if somebody
taxpayer is going to pay for this
i've been translating
in court hospital
in other places that you name it
for years
and i can tell you that in many
courtrooms
even people that provided by
professional translation company
certified
but translate completely wrong
[Music]
in court and i can see it
i can hear it and one of the defendant
criminal that if he's convicted he's
going to have to go to prison for a very
long time
he opposed because the person couldn't
even speak the language that he supposed
to translate fluently how could she
understand
what he had to say to defend himself
see so if the
was certified we already have problems
never mind the volunteers
and i
been helping a lot of people in
massachusetts into election and stuff
like that and they see the post and all
kinds of stuff and like roxanne said
the people that translate they held
their own mind and their own ideals and
who knows that who they tell to go to
vote so i also help a lot of people to
go translate and vote here in the state
of course i tell them to go vote
republicans because i'm a republican
i wouldn't tell them to go vote for
the democrats or other parties
so how do you control that
so we don't have problem
why do we create a problem
[Music]
so
i would respectfully asking you to
please
oppose this bill
don't create more problems because
whatever that translator interpreter
created during the election or in the
translation
who's gonna pay for the liability when
it goes to uh in the litigation who's
paying for that the taxpayer is paying
for that
we're done paying for it
so thank you so much for listening
thank you does anybody have any
questions
i'm not seeing any so thank you for
testifying thank you
that is the last pink card i have on
1442 is there anybody else who wishes to
speak um why don't you come on down and
i'm going to ask you to fill out one of
these pink cards please um you can do it
at the end i'd like to move along
because we're sort of a little behind
schedule here and if you can fill it out
afterwards and then
representative love would you do me a
favor and grab a pink card and give it
to this person yeah now i just saw them
oh okay so i got one before but i know i
see the pink cards thanks
thank you very much i am here to support
this bill and could you tell us your
name please my name is suzanne corby
thank you ceo rby i live in manchester
and i am part of an organization called
welcoming manchester that's affiliated
with the state organization welcoming
new hampshire
and our mission is to welcome immigrants
and to make our cities and our state
as welcoming a place
as we can for immigrants because we
believe that
having immigrants and welcoming
immigrants is a
win-win situation
people get to come here they get
economic opportunity they get safety
from disaster and war
and we get workers really competent
workers all along the line particularly
if you look in our nursing homes and
hospitals and rehab facilities you're
going to see a lot of immigrants working
and we believe that we need in return to
make them
as comfortable as possible
now becoming a citizen is a great
milestone
and people feel proud they work to do it
they feel proud of their success
but the second milestone is voting
because there's only two rights
that only citizens have one is to vote
and one is to serve on a jury so once
you become a citizen you
many people want to exercise that right
to vote
now
people will ask
if they become citizens don't they speak
english yes they speak english
the
expectation of reading
is lower
um and we don't have literacy tests for
native-born citizens either
um
but
the the reading level is generally okay
but when you start to read
complex material like how to register to
vote
the form how to register to vote
the absentee ballot form and those
directions
those are complicated they're
complicated for native english speakers
and
people don't feel comfortable
doing that in their second language
they need to have their first language
to make them feel comfortable it's not
only a welcoming gesture but it is also
an important
way in which we can give people
their rights as citizens
i was involved with
an effort in the manchester city
election in 2021
where we
had um
information printed translated
and printed
on
now we can't take these forms and tran
uh translate them that's not allowed
that has to go through the secretary of
state
and that's what i'm hoping that this
bill will do
but we did take the information in plain
english
and five other languages and had it
translated and we chose those languages
based on what the translating companies
often most often got we didn't use the
census
but the requests that they almost they
most often got
this was very well received it was used
by candidates
and it was used by
citizens who were preparing to vote
but what would really enhance this would
be to actually get those forms that you
fill out the registration form
and the absentee ballot form and any
other form and i don't think there's a
lot of them and i don't think the cost
would be very great
this is not interpretation it's not
having anybody go in and speak for you
this is paper translation
and that's usually about sixty dollars a
page maybe seventy five dollars a page
you choose um
a few of the most important documents
and the most important languages
it's not going to cost a lot
and it's just it's not only a way to be
friendly and welcoming
but it allows people to do to fulfill
their right as a citizen
any questions
any questions from committee members
representative derozan thank you madam
chair
and
this may also be a question for the
secretary of state i don't know but
thanks man for taking the question
is there anything in current law do you
know or what's the process in manchester
for town clerks that want to do this on
their own
in other words
does manchester do a ballot no spanish
it's english only no and that's i guess
probably a question
for the secretary of state it would have
to be approved by the secretary of state
so
and we did actually in 2016 request
write a letter to the secretary of state
and make that request and it was denied
but it was right before the election you
know there wasn't a lot of time there
wasn't a lot of budget left
and um
this law wasn't in effect uh
so you know they didn't have to do it
and
uh
but we can't just a private group can't
just take that
registration form and translate it it it
needs to be approved
by this it needs to come through the
state
thank you further questions from the
committee
thank you thank you thank you for your
time
on this
and that is the last person i have
as indicating wanting to speak on 1442
is there anybody else who wants to speak
on 1442
we did have people sign up
electronically to provide a remote
testimonial position on the bill
and signing up in support of it where
105 opposed were six
and representative
thank you
today um in lob six people have signed
up with a position
um with two
persons indicating
in favor
and four opposed um and i'm just to say
you know these committee hearings have
been fairly small but the blue sheet is
really to indicate if you're not
speaking because
if you speak them we sort of register
your opinion twice which is fine as a
committee we can certainly manage that
so with that i'm going to close the
hearing on 1442.
uh next scheduled for hearing is 1496.
hb1496 is requiring political
subdivisions to make voter checklists
available in spreadsheet form to any
resident the prime sponsor of the bill
is here with us today again thank you
for coming back this afternoon
representative love
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the election law committee um i want
to thank you for your services to me as
the the most important
um committee in in our in our
house
um
i believe i believe that the uh that
elect clean elections are at the root of
the the tree of liberty you know and if
we don't take care of our clean
elections we'll lose liberty
um i uh
i want to introduce house bill 1496
um and the reason behind it i was
talking to um
representative leon from derry and
prior to her becoming a representative
she uh she asked the supervisor of the
checklist in derry
if she could scour the the
checklist and um
you know she she's a mom of three uh she
didn't have a whole lot of time to do it
but she came up with 1500
um
people that were registered to vote in
derry that weren't there anymore you
know through death throughout the
removing some had been gone for five
years uh things like that then then they
did the ten year purge and found another
six thousand
okay that's 7 500
um you know registered voters that
shouldn't be there and
i found that
kind of appalling really um
you know it's um
once again you know the the root of the
tree of liberty uh we we can't have this
we have to take care of our elections
and uh and and really be vigilant and uh
and i guess it's up to us
to uh to be vigilant
thank you
questions for representative love
well so oh representative bergeron thank
you thank you madam chair representative
the first amendment
in the bill on line three requires that
the clerks
forward an electronic copy and
spreadsheet form to the secretary of
state
why
how would be how would it be made
available by the from the secretary of
state we're talking about people
you know from salem one in derry's uh
people from colebrook wanted hanovers um
you know if if if they have heard of any
discrepancies or or anything like that
that we should have
we should have the citizens helping us
you know it's further question follow up
uh well thank you for your reply uh and
i apologize if it sounded facetious
because i didn't mean to
um
were you aware then that when the
checklist is created at the city or town
level it's done so an election net in
pdf form or in a comma delimited file
and the secretary of state has access to
that electronic checklist already so
that there's no need for the clerks to
create one and then send it up to the
secretary of state
and the the second part of this bill
thanks for your question
um the second part of the this bill is
to make it available to any citizen at
no cost
you know to press a button on a computer
it shouldn't cost you know 75 dollars
okay uh we're not in the business of
making money we're we're in the business
of keeping elections clean okay thank
you
thank you further questions for
representative love
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to speak for this bill is
the honorable neil kirk
good afternoon madam chairman and
members of the committee for the record
i'm neil kirk
i live in where and although i was a
former representative or am a former
representative
i'm speaking for myself
i oppose this bill for six reasons
um
first
uh
should it pass
um and
as you know if it passes anyone can get
a copy of the check the public checklist
from the secretary of state in
electronic form
and that would be for the entire state
basically for every single community in
the state
while the law currently says that you
cannot use these checklists for
commercial purposes i think it would be
rather naive of the legislature to
believe
that
some people wouldn't take advantage of
this to get copies of these lists and
sell them to data miners and others
so as a practical matter not a legal
matter but it's a practical matter if
this bill were to pass
all of us would be receiving a great
deal more junk mail
perhaps junk telephone calls
but it would be an intrusion on
most people that they would find to be
very surprising and unnecessary
um because they've chosen to exercise
their right to vote
and now
they become part of some
data miners database
number two
there are many people in this state who
have registered to vote and many people
who haven't this would discourage those
people who haven't from registering to
vote because one of the consequences is
everybody's going to know this and as i
said a moment ago
you will get be getting all sorts of
junk mail etc as a result of your
decision to go public in this manner
under the bill
should you decide to register and vote
number three
if you read the fiscal note
most of a hundred thousand dollars will
be lost to cities and towns
right now the cities and towns get some
money from the secretary of state
and um that would go away under this
bill because there would be no charges
for this information in effect if you
vote in favor of this bill you're
raising local property taxes now i'll
admit that it's a trivial amount
overall a hundred thousand out of
billions of dollars that we collect in
state taxes in my town of where which
has a population of nine thousand uh our
town clerk said um if this bill were to
pass
as of 2021 the town of ware would have
lost 463
now that isn't a lot of money
but it is
the kind of thing that i hope this
legislature wouldn't want to put on
local property taxpayers
fourth
this
may be
a violation of the recently passed
informational privacy amendment
that's
2b in our constitution part 1 section 2b
which says uh government intrusion into
personal information is not allowed
there is no justification that i can
think of for expanding this that would
overcome
the privacy interests which that
amendment would is designed to protect
this also may be an unfunded mandate
if you read the fiscal note the
municipal association says that cities
and towns are going to have to come up
with some way to create an electronic
spreadsheet
beyond what they're already doing by
sending information in electronic form
to
the secretary of state no amount is
specified and certainly i suspect it's
not going to be a huge amount but again
it would be a requirement that the state
is imposing on
municipalities without paying for it in
violation of article 28a
and lastly
this bill may violate the federal
constitution
you know there's a section in the bill
section two that says only new hampshire
residents
can get this information
now that means that the secretary of
state is going to have to do two things
first of all require me to identify
myself and prove that i'm a new
hampshire resident
and then
give me this so the secretary of state
will now have a list of everybody
who acquire who requested this
information
that's a problem because it's an
unnecessary intrusion into personal
privacy especially under the right to
know law since you can get information
uh without identifying yourself but
here's the constant the federal
constitutional issue
um
article
4 section 2 clause 1 the citizens of
each state shall be entitled to all
privileges and immunities of citizens in
the several states
in other words one k state cannot
discriminate in favor of its citizens
and against those citizens of other
states
in this case the discrimination is we
only allow new hampshire residents to
get this information and not
residents of other states
and i'd like to
conclude by citing a very interesting
u.s supreme court decision where the
appellant
was the new hampshire supreme court
in this case a vermont woman this was in
the early 1980s a veront woman took and
passed the new hampshire bar association
and went to the supreme court to become
a member of the new hampshire bar
the supreme court said sorry you can't
become a member because we only allow
new hampshire residents to become
members of the bar
the supreme court said sorry you can't
do that that violates the privileges and
immunity clause and here was their their
statement
and i'm quoting we conclude that new
hampshire bar's residency requirement
violates the privileges and immunity
clause of article 4 section 2 of the
united states constitution
the non-residents interested in
practicing law is a quote privilege
unquote protected by the clause
although the lawyer is quote an officer
of the court unquote he does not hold a
position that can be entrusted only to a
full-fledged member of the political
community
a state may discriminate against
non-residents only where its reasons are
substantial
and the difference in treatment bears a
close or substantial relationship to
those reasons no such showing has been
made in this case
and so the new hampshire supreme court's
ruling
or requirement that a member of the bar
be a resident in new hampshire was
overturned
i think that's analogous to the
situation we have here there's no
justification for limiting this
information only to new hampshire
residents
so i believe that if a case were to be
brought this
or at least the second part of this bill
would fail for a violation for being in
violation of the federal constitution
madam chairman that concludes my
testimony i'd be pleased to answer any
questions if there are any
thank you
representative kirk and i i want to tell
you i am so happy to hear from you and i
am so happy i'm not disappointed that
you brought this smack dab into the
middle of privacy issues
um which we those of us who had the
honor of serving in the house with you
know was one of your personal uh focuses
and in fact uh had a lot to do with the
constitutional amendment so i want to
thank you for your particularly thank
you i'm not to disparage anybody else
for your testimony this afternoon nice
to see you question it's very nice of
you to say that madam chairman questions
representative barry uh miss matt i have
a series of questions um first which
thank you for being here representative
kirk i didn't have the pledge to start
with you but you're uh to echo the
chairman sentiment your
passion for privacy issues is well known
and a legacy that has out out currently
outliving your tenure as a former state
representative so congratulations on
that front and a minimum
um
first question is do you believe that
voter information is public information
yes yes
certain information is public
information we acquire all sorts of
information from a person in order to
register to vote including where you're
born where you were naturalized the name
of the court i mean all sorts of
information that
probably is not relevant to the public
but it certainly is relevant to the
public that
the names of people who have registered
who are registered to vote be known and
available to them in some format in some
form okay so and i guess you're getting
to the heart of what my next question
was because i heard about how smart you
were and you're showing that
um
currently i can go into the any town
clerk office any city clerk office ask
to see the checklist and and thumb
through it and i think in manchester you
can even get pdf copies of it for an
exorbitant amount of money um
what's the difference here i mean if
this is a privacy issue right and i can
currently see this information
right and there's really nothing stop
it wouldn't happen right but i could in
theory walk into
the town clerk's office start
transcribing this onto a piece of paper
how is
i'm trying to figure out how
turning it into a spreadsheet all of a
sudden makes it i get it makes it more
accessible but i understand like from a
privacy perspective how does that
turn it into i don't want to say
violation but infringement maybe
i think you answered your own question
it's a question of how accessible if
everything is on a time square bulletin
board and that's what you mean by public
public access
then
it's a
not just a degree but a but a totally
different situation than if you have to
go to 300 234 separate town
jurisdictions get something on a piece
of paper
put it into in in your home some sort of
electronic format and then disseminate
it or use it that's that's a totally
different situation
from what's proposed under this bill
which basically is the entire checklist
is available easily available electronic
form can be used for any
as a practical matter can be used for
any purpose
i see that as enormous difference
between the current situation and that's
why i'm here it it
it's it's a order of magnitude not just
an order of degree difference
further questions from the committee
representative alexander thank you madam
chair and thank you um honorable kirk um
so my question is um political parties
already have access to this information
um
why shouldn't the public
in by and large also have access to it
the i don't believe that the political
party should have access to it and i
was unsuccessful in preventing that from
happening
i certainly don't want to see an error
compounded by making this information
more accessible
i think we have
and have had for a number of years a
relatively fragile situation with
respect to voters you know all of the
voting controversy that's going on in
various states including new hampshire
and in congress
i want to make sure that voters feel as
comfortable as pos people residents feel
as comfortable as possible
with not only becoming voters
but actually voting
and i believe that to the extent one of
the prices that we pay for registering
to vote and voting is that everybody
easily knows what we've done and when
we've done it not who we voted for
um that that that kind of um
unnecessary publicity
would be a deterrent to
some folks
exercising uh their rights as as
citizens and so i'm trying to
prevent that and i think this bill
goes in that direction it's not a huge
step but it's another step and
i don't think we the legislature ought
to go in that direction
further questions
i'm seeing none
thank you very much thank you madam
chairman thank you members of the
committee
also signed up to speak on 1496's ken
eyring
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak
i'm very grateful
to all of you for allowing me to take
some of your valuable time i'm also
grateful to representative
dave love for putting this bill in
after
the
issues that arose in november of 2003
with elections across the country
there were a lot of concerns by a lot of
people not all those concerns were valid
maybe some of them were maybe they're
not but
it's difficult for people
to actually get in look at
get the information and be able to
determine whether or not there were
issues that need to be addressed
i agree with representative barry that
this is not a privacy issue you didn't
use those words but
what he said was
that this information is already
available publicly
but it's difficult to get you have to go
to every town
and you have to get the checklist from
every town you have to pay for that
it's my understanding that the
republican party and the democrat party
have access to these lists already
now
i don't mean to
sound like i'm talking down to anybody
but
when new hampshire constitution defines
we the people as the government all
power resides in the people in article 8
and then our magistrates and officers
are our substitutes at all time
accountable to us
so why should
the two parties have access to
information easily accessed information
that is very very difficult for us to
get
and very costly for us to get as well
i agree with the issue that
representative love
brought up about
too many people on the ballot those
those not on the ballot on the checklist
they need to get purged
and not
all of the supervisors of the checklist
do their jobs
we have
a woman in windham who was awesome
she was elected about 10 years ago and
she purged thousands of names from from
our checklist
if if people aren't
um eligible to vote their name shouldn't
be on the checklist
so i just want to address a few things
the reason to have it in a spreadsheet
format is because it makes it easy
to use
from an end user's point of view we can
sort it
and we can make
we can make better use of the data
um
the reason to have the towns do the work
instead of the state is because it
really reduces the the burden of the
state having to do that
i actually met with secretary gardner
last year to talk about this bill
specifically
and you know he suggested that it would
not be difficult for them to post these
on the website if if that were the case
um
i want to address the cost issue and i
agree with um
with the honorable
kirk
that uh you know towns might lose money
but it's minimal we're talking about
voter integrity
there are issues there are concerns
of many people in our country across our
country but even in this state as to
whether or not every vote is being cast
properly and if it's being cast by
legal voters
so if it's a few hundred dollars per
town when you divide that out across all
the residents in the town all the
properties in the town you're talking
about a dollar less than a dollar
aren't helping to ensure the integrity
of our elections worth that if you're
going to put a price on the value of our
elections
that's not really a price that's
that's really should even be considered
because it's it's nothing it's pennies
the state database i just confirmed this
with secretary of state
scamland the state database already
produces a spreadsheet
so the financial
note in here which says that the towns
would have to buy software is not true
they have access to the electronic
voter system and they can produce the
spreadsheet through that
they can then send that file it's a csv
file which is the spreadsheet format and
they can send that up to the secretary
of state
i'd like to just take a quick a brief
moment to address some of the issues
that
the honorable kirk had brought up
because i disagree with
with most if not all of them
so i did bring the first one was
that you can already get copies going
from going from each town to each town
individually
but again that makes that makes it
difficult for someone like myself who is
very concerned about voter integrity
from actually going through that process
why should i have to do that
this is public information it should be
available to me publicly i should be
able to go and if you don't want to
transfer this over to my town clerk up
to the secretary of state's office let
me get change this and let me get all
that information for every town from my
town clerk
all that's doing is throwing a roadblock
in my way as a citizen
whereas you as elected representatives
you don't have that roadblock that
doesn't make sense to me because i say
this with the utmost of respect because
i know you make a huge amount of money
you know
but you know your public servants
right i know you're here to do the right
thing but you're here to serve us don't
make our jobs more difficult
the second thing is that it would
discourage people from registering to
vote
that's part of the price of being a
citizen
and casting a vote
you register in the town
it's already public information i'm not
asking for somebody's date of birth i'm
not asking for all the fields
i'm only asking for the for the data
that would be given to me if i went to
my town clerk
and i asked for voter checklist in a
spreadsheet format
the fiscal note i think i talked about
that already
may be a violation of inform of
information privacy
this is already public information
i can already access it
uh it's a non-founded mandate you don't
they won't have to buy any software
so they already have the ability to do
this if i went to my town and i asked
using a right to know request i could
already get a spreadsheet so i'm only
asking you to make this easier for me to
not have to go from town to town to town
and it may
violate federal
constitution because only new hampshire
residents can get the info well
i can go
and i can go to any town
using the right to know law and i can
get a copy of the voter checklist i
don't have to tell them who i am i don't
even have to write any information about
myself i could just go there and i can
make the request and they have to honor
that request
a laws already allow me to do all of
this i'm just asking you to make it
easier for me
so thank you very much for your time
thank you questions for mr eyring
representative muirhead
thank you madam chair my my
understanding is that anyone can't get a
copy of the voter checklist unless the
the parties are the entities that can
get them am i confusing myself no i can
go to my town clerk i can i can put in a
request and i can ask her to give me a
copy of the checklist and she'll have it
ready in the day
further questions
i'm not seeing anything thank you very
much
uh suzanne corby
looks like suzanne has left
trisha pietsu
good afternoon madam chair and honorable
members of the committee my name is
trisha pietson with the secretary of
state's office and some of the testimony
i just wanted to provide to you kind of
has already been provided to you as
representative bergeron and others have
discussed this information it's already
currently available at any city or town
clerk's office matter of fact rsa 654 31
normal numeral tools which allows the
cities and towns to go ahead and provide
this information to any residents coming
into their
clerk's offices there is a fee involved
as stated in the fiscal note and
everything like that these monies that
as far as the statewide checklists that
are collected
from the party affiliations for those
that are getting it through the party go
back to the cities and towns but
individually any city in town when
somebody is going into the city and town
to purchase this list but also then they
would also be losing it internally as
well they wouldn't necessarily be coming
to the state they can also do it whether
it's a state rep somebody finding out
filing for alderman or a mayor that
would like to purchase a statewide list
they will lose the revenues from that as
well
one note i would like to make on this
too is that within this it states that
it shall be available in a spreadsheet
form to the secretary of state and that
checklist so corrected shall be used at
an election if it's applied to that that
means this would only applying six to 13
days before an election and not when a
supervisor of the checklist has an other
sessions
like they just had last evening and
everything
so but this information is already
available to
anybody that wishes to purchase it
it's just it's so it's available for a
fee and the monies would be lost would
be towards the cities and towns that in
turn uses money to continue to enhance
what they need for voting purposes
and with that i'll be happy to answer
any questions
questions from committee members
i'm not seeing any thank you thank you
also signed up to speak on this sister
son chester
thank you committee chair thank you for
hearing me today i just want to talk a
little bit in support of this bill
as you've already heard testimony it's
already available it's not always easy
to
acquire
there are some towns that give you a lot
harder time getting that list than other
towns we have actually had a
representative during the um during the
course of our trying to do
uh
our own little kind of voter integrity
process
actually get arrested
for trying to obtain this information so
it is a problem for the citizens of new
hampshire
it's a shame that we've gotten to the
point that our elections are such in
question um
for me they've been in question since
2002.
uh i've been i've been concerned about
the integrity of our election since 2002
and it has been falling on deaf ears for
many years so i am very
very thankful that a lot of this has
come to light but i think it's important
that we all recognize we have an
opportunity right now we have an
opportunity to be transparent for the
people that put us in the positions that
you folks are in we have a opportunity
to be to
understand that
although it may cost a property owner
one more dollar a month in property
taxes it'll be saving them thousands in
potential in potential legislation
that's actually
not advantageous to them
with regards to the fee that's involved
right now the parties the democratic
party and the republican party pay a fee
for this information and it's given back
to the municipalities shame on us
if that's the reason for opposing this
shame on us
it should not be about that the bottom
line is is that the people of the state
of new hampshire do not believe in our
in in our voting process
whether it's
legitimate or not they don't believe in
the voting process they don't believe in
in the the voting registry they don't
believe that the checklists are being
appropriately managed the bottom line is
is that we have a responsibility
to to the people of new hampshire to be
able to say
okay
we are going to be completely
transparent we're going to allow you at
no cost to do on your own time and on at
your own
expense
for
generating all these and canvassing and
things like that we're going to allow
you to prove that voting in new
hampshire is either good or bad and
we're allowing you to be part of the
process to fix with the problems where
they exist
the other thing that i like about this
spreadsheet being available is that
in my opinion it actually decreases
nefarious uh potential nefarious
problems with uh selling of data um
selling of data is a real thing whether
it's uh
you get the the registries going from
town to town or you get them on a
spreadsheet if i log in electronically
and i pull down
all these people
then there's a there's an ip address
connected to me and if i'm doing
something that i should not be doing
it's going to be easier for for the
powers that be to come to me and say
uh
whereas right now
you don't have to show any kind of proof
of who you are you can walk into a town
hall like i said some are better than
others but some town halls you can walk
in and say i would like this and they
say okay give us 20 minutes
and then you walk out with it you never
show an id you you never have to explain
why you wanted this information
and so i i uh support this bill for
exactly i think that this bill does a
good job trying to
um
further support the integrity of our of
our right right to vote in this state
thank you
any questions from the committee members
i'm seeing none thank you
the last person i have signed up for
this bill is chao kelly
thank you madam chair
um
so i would like to say that the thing
that president ronald reagan said trust
but verified
the second thing follow up on that is
stalin the communist leader he said that
it doesn't matter how many people vote
it matters who count the vote
and i've been following this since
november 2020 because i have no faith in
our election process
no election integrity i don't have faith
i still go through the motion of voting
but i don't trust it i need to verify it
and this bill um hb 1496
helped us me
to verify those facts myself
and
the honorable curt earlier is mentioned
about
the cost i mean the revenue lost by the
town
the first nation first in the nation
status of new hampshire earns new
hampshire business two billion dollars
two billion dollars
and we worry about the one dollar
something in the town for the cost
we need to prove this first in the
nation process is that we have the right
process and everything is done right in
new hampshire that's why we have that
status
right
and
but the junk mail
you know the most privacy of everything
that each of us being valid every day
that we don't know and not aware about
is the credit card every time you make a
purchase
they know everything about you
so this information of the voter
checklist it's a public information
which is a name
and the and who you registered to vote
and on a personal level
i got the phone call because i have a
lot of people registered to vote and go
to vote on election day both in new
hampshire massachusetts and actually
around the country
and you know what one of my friends here
that i know for 20 something years he
said ciao can you check for me to see if
i'm still like registered to vote
because i want to make sure i go to vote
november 3rd so like okay what's your
birthday and i go on the website check
it for him
he has been registered to vote as a
republican forever and in fact he
doesn't even know how to change it yet
on the website it shows that he's
independent
he's like what's independent
who changed that information for him
so i called the town
manchester and he said well you have to
come down and fill out the form you know
to change that back to republicans so i
met him there and helped him do that and
i asked them again
who changed that information
they couldn't answer that
so
with this list available to us easily so
that we can just go through it and check
it just but verified
without this information available i
would not know
until like people like that call and let
me know or they don't even know that
themselves and i help people register to
vote for the first time yet when i get
on the website
in massachusetts they've been registered
to vote and vote democrats for eight
years 15 years 20 years
i have records of that to show you
so i'm asking you
to please support
us
the peasants who supposed to be
the owner of this country
to get through the red tip because i'm
sick of that
the
political party had the power to do this
and that but we the little people are
the majority
that paying all the taxes
don't have that right
that is not right if we're talking about
all means are created equal our rights
are equal why are these political party
people have more power than we do
we should have the same right
access to the information so that we can
check and verify make sure it's a
transparent process so we can restore
our faith and trust in new hampshire
election process is voters integrity
issue here and this is a bipartisan
issue everybody's issue
thank you
thank you does anybody have any
questions
i'm seeing none so thanks thank you
that's the last speaker i have signed up
for 14.96
there were a number of people who signed
up to testify remotely 16 people signed
up in support of it 14 people signed up
opposed to it
and representative terozian is bringing
me the sign up for the legislative
office building today
which indicates that five people have
signed up for it which would include two
people who did not speak and the two
people who did not speak are in favor of
1496. i'm going to open close the public
hearing on 1496 and open our last
hearing of the day which is on
1383 which is relative to
electronic copies
of absentee ballot lists the sponsor of
this is representative barry and he is
here to introduce the bill
representative barry and i'm here on
behalf of myself for once so that's it
that's a nice change of pace for the day
um
this bill is a follow-up bill to um
legislation that we passed last year
for those who remember we
made the electronic
copies of absentee ballot requests
available to candidates whose name
appear on the ballot
that obviously had a bunch of moving
pieces in it if you recall from the
hearing
this bill is brought in to address some
of those issues i will be bringing an
amendment forward to this bill i'm
currently communicating with my city
clerk
who did do this in manchester
the bill the law went into effect before
the general election so i've been
talking with him about um
ways that we can improve it to kind of
lighten the the burden on the town and
city clerks um but also maintain
the intent of the legislation that we
passed um the
the bill as it is currently written
deals with the frequency in which the
um the list is made available ironically
enough my city clerk said ross isn't
daily a lot and i was like well you're
sending them out every day
so i may actually address the underlying
bill itself just to
accommodate the people that i represent
but that is the intention of this
legislation is to address issues with um
within within the laws we passed that we
we knew and i said in the hearing we
were going to find those and fix those
and get those tightened up before 2022.
questions for representative barry
representative lane
um
thank you madam chair and representative
maybe i'm looking at the wrong bill so
but how does this make it
i guess i'm not sure how having them
send it out within one business day
improves anything if not making it
harder and i'll follow up so go ahead
oh sorry uh how's um so the reason the
reason we want these lists um is
they are
when the when they send the ballot out
right um the the clock is then ticking
to if you're gonna have a conversation
with that voter say hey go vote for me
um the clock is ticking right and and
everybody in this committee we're all
election law nerds we know that a voter
who submits an absolute ballot can show
up on election day at the polling
location two hours at two hours after
the polls have closed has opened and
request a new ballot and vote but the
reality is is i'm not aware of a single
voter who has executed that i'm sure
somebody will have some anecdotal
evidence somewhere but we know that the
average voter doesn't understand that's
an option um
and elections you know once that ballot
is casts um you know it's over it's
effectively over it it is effectively
over so
when they're sending those out you know
i i do have the data from manchester and
i haven't had a chance to analyze um how
quickly the average voter is returning
it um but i do know just this is just
kind of me scanning the data from
manchester's 2021 municipal election so
i'm not holding this up as some massive
study um but it was a pretty quick
turnaround time i think it was less than
about three or four days with the
average like it would after the day
after three or four days after it was
sent because and manchester is kind of
unique because if you get the mail to
manchester at golf sals road it is
delivered in manchester the next day uh
so admittedly there's probably already
on an abbreviated window but you could
see that's the point of the addressing
the frequency is when the senate amended
the bill that we passed they tacked it
in with 91a provisions
which do have
the five day windows to respond
thankfully my city clerk did not
attempt to use that but you could see
why that could be a problem if you know
if i submit a request to get the
absentee ballot list and then the city
clerk says hey i'll shoot it to you on
friday well if he's been mailing monday
tuesday wednesday thursday
i don't get it until friday that's a
problem so i am going to address the
frequency
i don't know if i will go to daily
but i will probably keep it within two
days just because of what i was seeing
in the manchester um elections
the other thing we'll i'll attempt to
address will be
the data that was provided i believe
they were getting
lists sent to them from the secretary of
state's office at least this is what the
city clerk was conveying to me so they
weren't actually able to pull it
themselves they were getting the sos
office was sending it i believe they
were getting it every
i believe it was every tuesday and
thursday it was either monday wednesday
friday or tuesday and thursday i want to
say it was tuesday and thursday
and the data that was being provided was
incomplete and insufficient for the
average candidate to use i happened to
be smart on the average bear with
databases and i was able they were
sending the state voter id number and
they were sending the the other kind of
pertinent information relative to an
absolute ballot request so date
requested date mail and date returned
are the three other pertinent pieces of
information
so they were sending that so i had to
create a database using the state file
the the voter file
not to reopen that what we just went
through but i had to use the database
and use the the state voter id number to
cross-reference to that database to
generate who the voter was with their
relative information
it does create some problems because
there are
um
the
the databases that's available to the
political parties are snapshots in time
right so somebody registers after it
obviously they don't have that in the
database so we did have about in my
experience about five percent of the
absentee ballots that were being
requested we had no state voter id
number for them because we didn't
doesn't mean they're not legitimate
doesn't mean they're not real voters
just means we didn't have them um so i'm
going to try to address those issues as
well but it's going to be it's going to
be entirely a housekeeping bill to
tighten that and i said that when we
when i did the first time that we were
going to have to address things that we
didn't afford that we didn't see but
we've seen them and i'm trying to fix
them that was a really long answer to
your question i'm sorry yeah
follow-up
did i announce that i managed to get
around i'm not quite sure but give it a
shot okay so
not every town clerk well i guess most
city clerks are open every day but not
every town clerk's office is open every
day so
i don't know that they can comply with
this oh yeah no no so
i am going to fix it um but if the
original the original the the rsa that
we're editing
um because we we addressed this in the
hearing last time um it deals with days
that they're open so i i will write it
around there because i i am aware that
some are only open you know some of them
are open one full day and a half day um
right so i i will be addressing that yes
it it will not it's we we wrote it
originally around the days they were
open and this will be around the days
they were open okay so it's going to be
different than what we have now is that
what you're saying yes it will be
different than what we have now um you
know the i could only do so much when
when filing because when the bill filing
was due we hadn't actually conducted the
election so um i was just trying to
address issues that i knew of at the
time
but obviously now consulting with my
city clerk
other issues have arisen that he would
like corrected and and i don't i said
when we pass this i don't i'm not trying
to overburden the already hard-working
clerks um i am trying to get access to a
list that i think is candidates we do
need um but i'm trying to find a middle
ground so
these are all things that are going to
get addressed in the very long email
that my clerk sent me and he said ross
comma
okay thank you no follow-up further
questions from committee members
seeing none thank you for introducing
the bill
also signed up to speak to on this bill
is ciao kelly
ciao and i am going to ask you to keep
it to three minutes to the bill okay
we're going to talk about what the bill
is proposing to do
thank you
madam chair thank you
so i was
a voter i mean the observer for the
danville special elections a few months
ago and i was standing there
looking at them checking the s t ballots
and i checked
and they have miscount and
before that i was asked to stand like so
far away i could not hear anything i
could not see anything so i had to
request to stand close so that's why i
found
they count incorrectly
and so
so i brought it up to the moderator and
so he fixed that so it's helpful for us
to have
this uh absentee list
ahead of time so that we know
roughly how many when we do the
observing on the election day
and
also
i receive absentee ballot at my home for
november election which i did not ask
why
how many times and many people that i
know have the same problem
and also many times i know that they
don't check compare the signature
on the list
and i know people that show up to vote
and they say
you already voted absentee so you cannot
vote again
and i cannot be there to help them
so
this absentee ballot business is
important because i did not ask for
those absentee ballots and i my
understanding is before this covet
thing
is is you have to have the right process
to get them now they mess mailing it out
to everybody
that is wrong and they don't check the
signature so
please support this bill
thank you thank you does anybody have
any questions
i'm seeing none thank you also signed up
to speak i have a question
oh i'm sorry
representative prudhomme o'brien thank
you i have a question yeah
so you received an absentee ballot at
your home without requesting one yes you
said and and that's you live where
hooksett hooks it
did you
work with the ag's office to find out
what had happened you know what at the
time nobody even think about anything
you know i just received a lot of them
and i went to help with a lot like um
on the campaign trail so people said
like you know we need to count on the um
um absentee ballots so you know people
requesting absentee ballot they just
mail it to you whether or not you use it
they just mail it out
i should have kept that thank you thank
you and bring it for evidence
okay thank you thank you
all right also signed up to speak for
this is secretary of state david scanlan
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee
i just wanted to provide a little bit
information on the subject
under normal conditions i think that we
could supply
a list of absentee voters as this bill
suggests
however
we have a situation with our database
where we had a vendor
that was
that created it and maintained the
system
things worked incredibly well they did a
fantastic job
clerks were able to generate reports
that they needed along these lines and
in the past we had suggested that they
make these
reports for absentee voters available
once or twice a week
on a very regular basis
unfortunately
that company sold to another company
who then assumed the intellectual
property rights
and
that company has been doing an abysmal
job at maintaining
the software system to the point that
things that have been working just great
are not working properly now
it's forcing our staff up at the hava
office to
work on generating their own reports
which is resulting in the issues that
you see in man in manchester
trying to get things
timely so
we are trying to be as proactive as we
can with a situation we have drafted
an rfp a request for proposals
for
upgrading our
election net system so we can get out
from under the vendor that we currently
have
unfortunately it's going to take a
little time and i'm not optimistic that
we're going to have this ready for
the 22
2022 elections
certainly 2024 um
you know we expect that this will be
going smoothly but i just wanted to make
the committee aware
of that situation because it does impact
you know how you might address this
legislation
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
representative terezian thank you madam
chair thank you uh
mr scanlon
so if this
bill were to pass the house and pass the
senate and
be enacted in 60 days
the governor is signing it
how would you deal with that
well
obviously we would deal with it
with the language in this and i'm
anxious to see the amendment
and hopefully they can have some input
but in this
in this bill it says um
uh
you know should be provided
notwithstanding rsa 91a4 such copy shall
provide it within one business day of
the request
it it implies that it's
you know i would read this as being the
most recent
copy of the list that's available
even if it's three or four days old
so you know if
if the request is made in and produced
in 24 hours it might be the same list
that you know the same person requested
three days ago
obviously we understand the need for
this
and you know we want to make sure that
the lists are up to date and that
candidates especially get
you know
up-to-date accurate information on
absentee voters so that they can
run their campaigns
but
under the current condition producing a
list within 24 hours
is unrealistic
follow-up representative so under the
current
climate with the current vendor how long
would you expect it to take
if not in one day do you have an idea
roughly trisha how long do you think it
would take
um
yeah but if
if we if we had in place a system forget
the vendor
keep them up to date within two or three
days
tuesdays and fridays
and fridays tuesday and friday okay
representative alexander
no go ahead
thank you my question my question was
answered there because in the the
primary in 2020 i was doing things like
writing to voters that requested ballots
and it was
the lists were kind of older so i i
guess like the turnaround time i think
you answered it was like three days or
so right
okay
further questions for deputy for
secretary scanlon that's going to take
me a minute i apologize it's taken me a
minute too i apologize
yeah
okay i'm not seeing anything so thank
you
all right we did have so i have no other
speakers signed up for this bill
um so i'm
the testifying list remotely
indicated that for house bill 1383 five
persons signed up in support of the bill
for signed up in opposition to the bill
and
representative terozian has provided me
with the sheet that provides that two
people here in lob signed up in support
of the bill
that concludes
my the public hearing on 1383 which is
now closed i want to thank everybody for
their attendance and attention today
we will reconvene tomorrow at 9 30.
thank you
i guess
uh
oh
you